et oui ça l'ufab ça va ouais mais tout
le monde
bah ouais ça va ça va ça va ça va
tranquille beaucoup je prends le match
je serai toujours chaud chaud comme la
braise alors attends juste fab je suis
en train de contrôler un peu l'écran la
de début j'ai déjà perdu le truc que je
voulais faire voilà c'est la pac jeu
juste mettre le hosting tu vois sur la
chaîne bitstream histoire qu'on y soit
voilà on est bons fab
j'ai quasiment tout fait je suis
quasiment la femme à plat tu me vois je
suis là sans être là ce que météo là bas
je sais pas je fasse très attention j'ai
regardé hier en plus ce que je
n'arrivais pas à dormir le l'épisode
attends je suis en train de chercher le
voilà la série black mirror est le
miroir noir série où le mec complètement
sueur 28 à il contrôle des gens dans un
d'intelligence artificielle dans un jeu
enfin en fous j'ai plus de vingt star
trek
ah oui et du coup le match est déjà
parti du coup pendant que j'étais là que
j'étais pas là bon déjà ouest et se
surajoute comme ami et c'est parti fab
et ça joue déjà d'entrée alors à temps
pour une raison x ou y g l'évaluation
motor sales et c'est bah écoute ils sont
partis alors il a suffi c'est la seule
fois où tu vois notre vision sur trois
quatre minutes de retard la non l'afld
directement 18h pile quoi so so plus à
prendre ne peut s'en fiche a versé son
anniversaire c'est quand même une
information première malin ce que c'est
une exclusivité midstream le
l'anniversaire de sociaux là tout le
monde personne le sait cela nous oui
alors est-ce que tu connais son âge
parce que tu sais car il a aujourd'hui
[Musique]
24 ans allez on fait ça fait quoi en
fait j'avais tenus ont fait le chaud le
froid rêvons pas trop directe 25,25 m
moi je te pas moins un bon on arrive
toujours au chaud froid quoi à 2 2 un
choc est allé d'un chat c'est génial
c'est qui ce charme a vu qu'on est très
heureux quoi
bah du coup est-ce qu'on est toujours
pour visiter le gange ou espagne plutôt
pour le chat aux yeux bleus cheveux
du coup je répète pour le shore ray mais
réussit assez chiant fin on était pour
une éternité pour visiter la ce chat est
immense et son chat ça que ça change la
donne
est ce que c'est vrai que ce serait une
grosse info que tu lâches reda d'entrée
de stream quoi parce que premières infos
qu'on l'a annoncé son anniversaire 12e
un fou et son chat
magie jeux chaque fois cet acheminement
alors c'est un chat qui la trouve sur
internet et il a foutu la m
pour quoi faire peut-être si l'avenir
les charges c'est pas enfin pour lui
comme ouais moi je sens quand même c'est
son chasse avec la logique voudrait que
ce soit son chat mais c'est un peu la
question qu'on a envie de poser sur la
chase comme tout de suite que je leur
écris de saison il faut les interviews
d'après match là peut-être il faut la
règle à ce que la jeu sinon ils ne vont
pas penser à poser la seule question
intéressante du truc pourquoi je sais
tout vertueux bah oui et que des trucs
de moncaut les droits diagnostiques bas
alors qu'il ya quand même l'information
de la journée koala qui est ce chat en
tout cas il est pas mal souvent pour le
moment je ne connais pas quoi ou pas
rouler ou les couettes momar faye qui
raconte qu'en allant de la merde il a
juste un pion de moins et c'est de la
merde mais demeure un tournoi où il
attaque et 6,6 à fond je pense qu'il est
heureux fois il ronronne go non il est
bien il est bien là où il est il un pion
- ils se disent et de l'esprit à fond
peut-être je donne même une pièce quand
un moment donné tu vas faire fou
directement je me mets glide stream dans
la poche quoi c'est peut-être un jeune
chien s'est vu la vidéo de ce matin et
c'est ça c'est quand même enfin très
mécontents oui les commentaires préféré
ne sont pas pour moi que se passe-t-il
et où il a appelé reines chevaliers bon
tu sais si tu fais un indice pour toi
c'est dacia il peut faire ces
singulières visite la veille peu basique
qui vont s qui va autant gaffé contre
que contrat andriatiana s'il veut une
chance dans le match au new bag
mais bon normalement il doit être plus
fort que ce qu'il a montré qu'on
travaille asean quand même ouais mais là
je sais pas si le renfort jeudi
olympiens devraient pas épargner jeune
ben ça arrive après 1 mais bon une fois
était en fait peut-être on est où là on
est sur le puits de choc chez ce gamin
ouais je sais aussi aux départs des
stream
ouais c'est toujours c'est en fait je
vais le chat mais c'était pas hyper
actif mais le chat en pluie sont pas
hyper actif non les ventes essais f1 dès
que c'est plus une arena et fut
personnes par voiture ayant aussi sauf
d'ailleurs chili 1 sur les arénas ils
ont commencé à assumer partie beaucoup
plus que celle des autres parce qu'ils
ont compris que bon il ya des parties
ont envoyé des pièces en un pour le
plaisir quoi alors que bon management
sur ces 5 le problème c'est peut-être
qu'il ya dimpre emprise et qui arrive
est roi il va récupérer depuis on sait 5
ouais mais où sa soeur de son match et
peut-être foulée 5 pouces écartés tu te
couvre quoi très haut débit 3g fou b5
taxe à tour ils bougent la tour tu fais
pousser 4 il fait peut-être qui des deux
enfin je veux dire là si tu fais pas
c'est simple on vote ce couple là il a
fait don il a réfléchi 1040 est aussi
c'était ok mais c'est chaud il a pris
avec 5,6 menacé le set mais bon
maintenant il avait 2-3 attaquer là bas
c'est beau ça j'ai une qualité quoi
c'est dans l'esprit si tu prend effet
engrangé 5 on menace pour chad dawson
mais c'est horrible et on a l'option
paseo qui est chiant et les forces au
quand même d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a été
jouée fab ouais pas si clair c'est trois
fuites qui est prend ses mythes tout
reprend après y aura droit aux sectes
venir flopée le pion c'est chaud quoi
c'est ce qu'ils jouent d'ailleurs fabre
s'est tendu un barrage je sais pas qui
est mieux faille at il quelqu'un qui est
mieux d'ailleurs qui bien moche tu veux
que je te fare tous les deux mais
peut-être moins bien qu'avant puisque si
les pions se met à avancer ce sera mal
non il ya 2 3 au 7 e tour ses six
trophées qui ceci tombe bien ouais ok
sur tour66 si la tourbe et 6 du coût
autour c'est autorisé dépasse très bon
petit nul peut-être cet effet des 4es
machin tu joues pas tu vas pas faire nul
n'a quand même pas c'est un peu abusé
non tu peux toujours que je suis pas con
28 en deux sets
franchement non sage ou non ça peut
jouer le jeu alors johnson j'espère une
star indienne mais bon tout cela passe
souvent des semaines soit enfin qu'un
effet il compte nakata 4 po qui commence
aux échecs par où commencer
yann harlaut ce qui ne pas qu'on sait
cette drogue est peut-être un bon
conseils de marc loos
ouais c'est vrai que c'est intéressant
comme je t'en auras du mal à s'arrêter
je m'en vais il a senti que le jeu était
trop tôt trop intéressant pour lui qui
pourrait pas à lutter tu vois après il
s'est dit bon je préfère retourner à
forte mike quoi c'est au moins je suis
sûr de ne pas avoir de risque et tu vois
je bah ouais tu en as on a réussi à tout
sauver ta capot quoi du coup c'est
génial en fait c'est comme ça il
faudrait faire le marketing
échec vraiment c'est à l'école et où il
emmène on ne commence pas c'est trop
dangereux
les entrepôts la cigarette non ça va ça
tu pourras peut-être arrêter ça c'est
bien ça encore les échecs non là c'est
fou c'est bien il est vraiment parti en
fait c'est fantastique
oui on va falloir qu'on est en train de
réussir notre mission qu'on a réussi à
dégoûter une nouvelle personne des
échecs bravo à toi qu enfin c'est génial
on va écouter il ne reste plus que 50
mille en france avec toujours la merde
alors tagab au bas du coup nous failli
nous sommes en train de faillir à notre
mission malheureusement pas j'ai peur
que tu fus temps dans mon avis me disent
oh l'énorme séduction désolé pour toi
six jeunes attaquent à la st cap pas cap
odeur s'est pas tu as il s'est peut-être
un gamin il a peut-être dix ans et 12
ans 13 ans ou de 20 tonnes en fond
sonore
babe fait 28 28 ouais ouais donc du coup
est ce que tu es pour ça il donne une
éducation voir des échecs le patron
clubs ont plus de trois conseils du
maître tu peux prendre le risque
par où commencer je sais pas il
attendait ou en fait c'est bouger pièce
quel est ton niveau actuel déjà ait eu
un niveau des débuts de justine et même
pas de toi moi non mais bien sûr cela
parce que les vastes voilà tu peux
commencer par les trucs basiques
d'apprendre les maths tous les tableaux
de maths un peu des petites finales
facile des choses comme ça c'est
peut-être h et la brière des échecs de
tarsacq au vert les gens il vient
généralement fab et le comment battre
pas posée chaque île et bien je sais pas
mais je suis pas non plus je n'ai
cherché à mon fils mais je suis pas sûr
que je suis pas sûr ou ma fille d'air on
ne sait pas on verra bien sûr ça marche
je suis pas sûr en tout cas c'est après
la lecture du livre direct voilà je
l'inscris directement championnat du
monde
là j'ai eu au moins 80 et dégage il va
gagner faire attention voilà tu tombes
sur un coup franc fort que vit cote est
dégoûté mais le thème de l'eau
d'ailleurs il m'a déjà sokolo t-il fait
déjà des speechs s et de partout quoi
s'inquiéter il est bien qu on va te papa
ba écoute vata capot va pour combattre
papa aux échecs après tout un chacun à
voir c'est pas le choix ça pas mal pour
vraiment débuté au top là d'autres
livres sur internet des exercices des
trucs sur shop.com spaemann est à
l'abonnement refait ce point comme après
mais ça c'est si tu es vraiment évolué
ouais ouais t'es pas obligé de commencer
tout de suite comme ça bannwart ce point
comme après l' avantage c'est qu'il
n'est pas très chère femme non ces
boîtes roses euros par an en dollars
mais je dois dollars par mois
il ya beaucoup trop d'infos vrai mais
c'est vrai que j'ai ce point comme c'est
le site est trop bien sûr c'est un peu
comme les échecs c'est dangereux c'est à
dire que là tu sur un terrain dangereux
c'est là c'est sûr le jeu est trop
intéressant relaté sur le site leader du
truc donc si tu veux tu es bref en temps
d'adaptation c'est pas évident c'est pas
évident
ouais c'est dur femmes la légende en
chat ils ont ils ont de la peine pour
eux pour ta capot un choix qui sait pas
où il a mis les pieds en fait c'est à
dire [ __ ] les deux sont vraiment con
j'ai l'habitude des sram switch et tout
ça mais là ils m'ont l'air plus contre
les eaux je pensais que les échecs s'il
était intelligent et là il se dit merde
mais t'inquiète pas il ya que nous en
fait un cerf que les autres c'est plus
sérieux c'est là tu es tombé sur le
mauvais stream en fait t'as pas de
chansons faites pas capot vraiment c'est
encore t'es sur la scène chaise comme
c'est ça va encore c'est sur la chaîne
du stream c'est c'est pire encore là
c'était sur la chaîne mii stream s'est
tu vas encore tomber plus bas quoi j'ai
peur qu'à étudier lui veut déjà qu'ils
fassent des gambie tués dont il faut
déjà des envies de base vous en ferez
d'où le sacrifice de fou sur leur accès
baril après un peu débutants comme truc
mais est mais n'est pas très bien mon
saut et n'a besoin que de sept fins
adverse mais il est fou quand il parle à
les choux
puis enlève cette un peu l'attaqué voilà
onze requêtes idiotes sur dans l'esprit
fait des graves n'inquiète pas mal joli
tour à sept mois c'est sûr ça réduit la
pression sur sa rehab sont peut-être un
peu sur le fou aussi cas pour se barrer
ouais c'est dur bon et le clou il va
récupérer à vrai dire un femme
d'affaires four b3 l'autre va faire tes
lycée 3 il va le récupérer mais ce qui
va faire mieux parce que spawn juste un
petit floor opposer notre petit nul
ouais mais tu vois moi ça me ferait
plaisir une petite nul là dans celle là
dans le sens où une victoire de visites
dans le sens où tu as is a accroché dès
le début en fait ça me rassure je suis
rassuré la dette les plus proches en bas
âge prime focus pour le gange
le chabab ont discuté un peu avant mais
mais le grand quand même s'est passé ça
que ça se calme le fleuve sacrées du
gange quoi donc du coup fatal est ce
qu'on peut et est-ce qu'un chat peut se
placer au-dessus arbitrairement du gange
je suis parfois demandé at il dit
deuxième question ouais bah tu déjà vu
la véritable peau du gange
parce que el pueblo l'a fait donc avant
que les auteurs des joueurs à la fin
quoi non plus qui s'appelle guja quoi du
coup goudjo c'est vrai que c'est un dieu
ou une déesse du gange peut aboutir
peut-être bien les charentais l'arrivée
du bus pour se rendre du goût déjà de
partout quoi si on peut s'asseoir à la
table du lion je demande à jojo va mal
et à 4 à 3
c'est le fleuve comme une propreté je
séjournais et c'est très propre jeu au
large
quant à la petite propos de à à à la
venue du beauf de partie 2 nuls dégage
mais c'est une série que jusqu'où
peut-on aller et le match est inverse du
gris tchouk 12h28 nul d'affilée dégager
tous cas une victoire la fin elle a
changé de l'analyse plus forte points 4
ce sera je serai pas la ligne your tayev
noir avec des 3 e les 3 m et vont sévir
terre séchée truc du cran c'est très
très fort maintenant il n'ya pas plus du
billet le chan h dans le gange me grange
deux coups de patte dans le chat de
poing supériorité à des revues comme
dans le pierre feuille ciseaux je pense
c'est un puits quelques pas
tu as ta ta ta les sionistes c'est
complètement d'accord avec toi
il pense que pour devenir un vrai joueur
débutant bah ouais tu sais pas mater en
fait n'était pas un vrai joueur mais
c'est chaud parce qu'en fait tu peux
manger toutes les pièces de l'adversaire
mais si tu sais pas comment mater à la
fin un peu chiant d affaires d échec par
toulouse voit partout ça prendra des 50
coup c'est plus drôle à regarder quand
les spectateurs
le roi se bat rethel attraper enfin fou
c'est très difficile à la fin à tien qui
avaient des quatre jeux tactiques
alliage 5 c'est très attention est ce
que c'est si fort
attention c'est un pager si ces
intentions n'ont surtout pas mais
causant reporter f4 f5 y est tout est
horrible vous me trouvez tableau de
match et ce point comme je sais pas tu
peux tu peux mais à fo avoir labo noir
cédant les drisses après ou sait plus
comment ils appellent ça mais ouais tu
peux les trouver un terrain qui ne
s'avoue pas l'aréna dit arrête tu vois
les gens qui ont raté la reina d'hier
ils sont ils sont en sueur des super
génial et c'est pas voté trois tours
mais d'être tout seul sur l'échiquier
battlezone l'a23 quoi dans ces cas la
tour total va pas ma tête vous réduire
le roi tulameen sur une bande tu le
laisses bien tranquille la bao chau
battu avec toi aussi
et puis moi tu veux matin peu de plein
fouet assez génial en fait on a appris
le matin croyez toujours en l'espace de
15 secondes c'est fou mais c'est de la
pédagogie en bar là ce que tu viens de
faire c'est sebo femme catherine amar
fall chef mais jusque là il a fait
d'aveux de en fait tu ailles à protéger
le pion détroit nous je pense qu'on l'a
les non juifs au g4 quoi bon super les
la dame et alors non c'était dans
l'esprit tu as des chances de perdre sa
partition presque les dames c'est pas un
peu surcoté fable
ces surfaces et sur femmes bon alors
cette position faible c'est pas si clair
le vie dit il a réussi à parer les
assauts de socoa le show ce qui se
retrouve un peu bête d'ailleurs mais bon
j'étais obligé de la faire fabriquer
j'ai une check list si tu veux des
blagues sont obligés de faire dans le
seau plein de trucs qu elle
cette position est pas terrible elle est
un peu soso même en anglais tueur ont
réussi à les assauts les la sauvette se
prend du damache cathy la sermat est en
fait comme une merde et plus de femmes
que je t'annonce victoire de visite ne
peuvent plus continuer d'être dans un
club pour progresser donc tu peux être
une opposition je pense pas qu'ils aient
enfin j'attends un très bon niveau sont
allés en octobre c'est pas du tout
obligatoire alors vous a lâché une info
dans le chatt unique visite est malade
un jour ça c'est mana de 20,6 ou reaper
énormément les sodas place avant d'être
la roue tourne en pl à 120 miles son
anniversaire ça fait peut-être suis-je
pas à toi est-ce que tu auras envie de
jouer le jour de son anniversaire
non je vais faire cette année stockholm
mais du coup bah là j'ai déjà joué pour
mercer rarement c'est le 5 janvier ya
pas trop de temps donc tu lâche l'info
tu t'installes anniversaire ouais si
jean launay tipi ce jour là tu vois un
truc comme ça je n'y tiens pourquoi pas
très intéressant du coup femme mes sauts
il est vraiment pas très bien enfin il a
fait n'importe quoi comme on rentre chez
toi comme tu prends ton roi tu as sur la
caisse du délai pour le rock depuis la
tourner vers tout seul jet montré après
construire une nouvelle partie mais
c'est vraiment son anniversaire en fait
c'était pas une blague les gens qui y
croient pas vraiment idéal c'est encore
une connerie non là c'était vrai si tu
ne peux jamais savoir en fait c'est ça
qui vient sur cette chaîne c'est que
t'es jamais vraiment un abricot à l'abri
ça peut être une vraie info qui est
lâché c'est une partie un peu étrange
vraiment j'ai envie de dire une partie
un peu sans queue ni tête pour shot c4
ouais c'est un peu sans foi ni loi
mais du coup ils bossent piola sow
gagnant maintenant obligé de par la
qualité c'est bon c'est un jeu que
richie le modem n'est donc laissé capi
et prend b2 dd com peut-être que tu dois
prendre ces deux en fait plutôt genre
prend 2,5 pour un essai 2 je n'ai pas
super y arriver mathaf patron femmes
puissent 26 ans des deux moments on
reprendre sept tours en d2 praxis ne
faut pas prendre cinq avants sont eux le
fou 17 en l'air à la fin
rist avait changé les plans d ailleurs l
flo7 à la forme - des pages web et
visent ils recommencent à gaffer quand
il y en a marre tu sais pas si on doit
pas s'énerver la fable des bas mais
paraissent qui veut tenter fourbe et 50
premiers je vois pas trop à quoi ça
servirait mise à part mettre une pièce
de plus pris sans prise non mais c'est
grave quand même de se rendre à ce
niveau là ne s'est pas concentré puisque
le ça était vraiment malade déjà contre
russian était peut-être déjà malade mais
47 ans longtemps qu'on bat est aux
olympiens il était malade s'il est
malade depuis un mois il n'en peut plus
il a vraiment vu les eaux du gange quoi
et la food and then vous éblouissent et
dimanche très intéressant je peux voir
la véritable eaux du gange où il a
essayé depuis il a dû mal quoi des
petits problèmes d'intestins je pense
qu'on peut vraiment mourir d'un truc
comme ça
fab 2 de new york oui je pense que tu
peux avoir des bactéries assez méchante
dans un truc comme ça
pas assez bon c'est bon c'est mon
opinion avant sais rien je suis pas
docteur mais à des bactéries la basse le
times pour les petites bactéries d'ici
là en plus c'est les bactéries lequel on
n'est pas habitué ouais mais pas les
nôtres en suisse du coup faut passer
sous le feu de trucs pour le manger tous
mpt
bon vouloir la gagner seul sans les
dames pas eu grande partie 1 pour le
moment beaucoup d'erreurs il va falloir
que visite ils recollent vite au score
un fab parce que parce qu'il n'a pas
l'air d'être juste pas je le sens pas
d'abord non non je ne sens pas un
mordant il pourra du thé après donc bon
c'est bon sinon bah jeannot est bouilli
mieux mieux mieux ré j'ai pas
l'impression de voir des partis
virevoltante nan ça a l'air d'être
beaucoup de on va avoir de la catalane
il avoir des échanges du jeu très fermé
donc complice et fond de court est à un
moment ça se débrider mais c'est vrai
que pour l'instant bon aucun respect
pour le moment elle est des petits trucs
théorique taille que qu'il se restaurent
beaucoup vie dit c'est bien mais enfin
attention à la gestion tout bien s'y
prête une barre d'énergie comme dans les
jeux vidéos qu'il faut remonter ses
points de vie quoi ses points de vie
quoi
ouais j'en ressens qu'il n'a rien obtenu
un nouveau enfin sur cf
bah non mais il n'a rien fait je sais
pas enfin sorti couverture palmarés
l'hadopi dit j'égalise quoi les clans
c'est pas évident contre un joueur comme
ça m'avantage nature faut faire gaffe
après 3 il peut carrément se faire
enfermer de cavani qui n'aurait plus de
cases
peut-être que ça va encore mais je
repars es tu vois le genre de piège 9,1
me 3,4 us 5
un oubli qui est discret mais c'est
surtout ses cinq frères tous reprend des
cinq sur f5 à cavaillon 5 jusqu'à j'ai
vu mais je me dis est-ce qu'on peut pas
prendre les faire un tour d'essai doit
cesser exactement ce que je pensais bah
voilà qui peut ce soir tu as tort mais
je pensais à ça mais juste moi je
pensais la chemise et de l'avs après tu
as que à 5 tu as du coup pour of non pas
du coup visiteuse à serra pas moins à ma
table quoi mais eux
mais s'assure sont enfermés fab en fin
de tournoi à vii alors elle est quand
même enfermé absurde soit et en rangs
des 6es x 3 way
ouais c'était beau ça je vais montrer
femmes formées il est vraiment fort en
fait soit il saute sur toutes les
occasions mais bon la forme ils arrivent
à se débattre avec sa tour ouais mais
ouais
marc four b2 peut-être qu'il a le temps
de il va se reprendre euh f7
d'improbables je reprends un filtre sur
miles kane est juste vous prend b2 mais
tours d2 peut-être après tu te bon tu
trouves tu as toujours tirs de bombes
b-61 thérèse meyer métral fonds de 3
après sur un joueur sur le clouage est
facturé à tours en d2 il reprotage raz b
6 non mais il est rapide de saw dit qui
se mouche beaucoup 1 / / / son écran
sais c'est pas très bien élevés c'est
génial on va se plante pas c'est un peu
dégueu quoi enfin voilà panne on était
venu pour te mouche et août et du porge
aux échecs joseph à c'est génial que les
mecs jouent malades et tous et deux
abrutis s'en prennent à lui alors que
vont faire ou si on peut plus quoi il se
dit fou tu es tu pour te fous chez telus
pour flo c'est l'échec c'est bien de
demander ça quand même
méline tu vas en partie en vrai le mec
seul ou si tu lui demandes ça c'est
fantastique non rage le fait la
prochaine fois que j'ai une partie en
réel que le mec se bouge lui demande
telus pour te mouche et aux tenues pour
jouer aux échecs
franchement c'est vous aussi je fais ça
non
[Rires]
qui es-tu en relief trois sauts dans le
sprint je suis tellement heureux de ma
blague mais non c'est fini
ouais tu vois il ya eu viol il n'aime
pas le survêt de socoa et contrôlés sur
votre dos au versant sa sueur en est
d'ailleurs un peu moche
honnêtement je dors sur vote de saint
louis ou de de webster j'ai perdu le
soin qui calcule un tout cas s qui
calcule f3 non j'aurais eu du tout c'est
ça qu'on va être un pion enfin point f 4
et peut-être fou des 4 b 1 et tours
c'est 8 tu vois mais après tour des six
tu as face à tous ces cinq 4000 cas tour
b1 pour ces huit jeunes en prend aux
fous et tour des six jeux par contre on
prend un temps fou quoi
du coup tu es tour ces deux et royal
sont un miroir f3 peut-être et le roi va
courir vers leucate et c'est chaud après
tout ces 5
tu peux aussi donc je suis fait refouler
deux directs il faut aussi s que nous
fermions 520 j'étais très heureux je
suis pas trop le pour lui on voit tout
wen à tour sain qui peut faire de même
et peut-être fait tourner dos du coup
sur coup mais deux maintenant on prend
un temps fou à ton pion du coup
notamment à leurs yeux
ce que l'on trouve le no fake de cette
variante qu'elle est mieux ou pas je
sais pas c'est tendu fable pour le
moment ce match et on est pas on n'est
pas très très nombreux à le suivre je te
le dis tout de suite ni combien bat
ensuite le dire je sais pas mais je sens
qu'on n'est pas nombreuse qui a personne
dans le tchat
il ya des personnes qui a cliqué sur les
liens tout le monde s'en fout en fait
personne n'a regardé notre pré match
c'était génial tu veux que je te dise
combien on est saisissant 560 web c'est
pas énorme c'est bien ce que je disais
ouais bon femme maintenant on a des
habitudes différentes pas mal moi moi il
ya écrit 380 honnêtement on ce peuple
innu troll non 380 fabre je sentais
qu'on n'était pas autant parce que
j'écris 875 sombre oui mon mon truc
écrit 300 à 380 je te demandais au fake
chat obligé de me faire un stade ça va
être horrible à ces vases il faut que tu
fasses tu m'envoies paroisse ap ben
watson d'avoir le no cry et elle manque
ou quoi c'est fantastique c'est
tellement beau quoi dans mon mieux
garantir aux releveurs des mets qu'ils
écrivent des chiffres il ya pas de no
fake je t'ai envoyé nos fans bah alors
voilà je vais prendre le no fake
alors c'est difficile vérifiable ouais
ouais il ya no fake ya le no fake c'est
vrai qu'il ya nos têtes mais alors rien
ne me prouve que tu l'as pris maintenant
la photo peut-être sauvé dit tout à fait
un montage photo est ce que c'est un
vrai no fake vous allez je vais mettre
ça sur twitter pour que les vérifie que
non mais bon on n'est pas beaucoup a
personne qui parle quoi
mais pas beaucoup en parler mais c'est
génial à fait apte à l'habitude d'être
mille deux mille personnes non mais bon
là peut-être que sow il peut peut perdre
ouais il peut sauter ouais en fait c'est
passé en page en page d'accueil twitch
c'est pour ça en fait arrêter dans les
300 et tout d'un coup j'ai en tant qu on
a ça qui peut faire pire ces trois
semaines d'arrêt je vous rends pas une
pièce avant même sa bien vu
bah oui mais moi te dire oui on regarde
tu pouvais faire ça c'est joli comme est
un je suis à ce que je sois sûr ce
serait pas joué ben tu es nul tu es nul
bas test face sur france étroite on
prend à six équipes avec la pièce de
moins est permis oui mais j'ai raté
quelques faire d'autre hi hi hi hi sous
ici il sue c'est le petit jean galice où
là qu'on peut se faire tu vois on peut
chanter une archos tu peux tu peux
chanter aussi si tu veux femmes il y en
a tant déçu
qu'est ce que c'est peut-être un ou deux
contres clous et que j'avais vu beaucoup
plus vivant que fabianski bien ce que je
dis pas qu'on entend du coup oui mais
bon petit verre imprimé froid comment tu
me lis quoi tu peux pas te prendre pour
ces trois tours je suis 30 30 secondes
ou sur trois tours de suite j'agis pour
pour te débattre objectivement
d'ailleurs la chance de me dire ce que
justifie dissous bah en fait faut faire
faut connaître is it has du coup dessus
connais pas résister à ce que tu tu
apprécies tu as sur youtube et une fois
que tu connaîtras résistance mais
peut-être hors-jeu un échec et le
football mais enfin
non il va tenter la tante elle comptait
quelque chose
by a peut-être tenté tours à huit après
tu as fait fi tours à huit mois du coup
il monte le roi à petit la fare f5 medef
5 des trucs pour être présente sur deux
réseaux pmr est ce que tu fais pas
contre réseauter après sou est un sou
j'aime bien les gens âgés loi qui
cherche des explications pourquoi on est
beaucoup et les gens qui regardent avait
en fait mais beaucoup juste que c'est
bien enfin gea voilà faut le savoir
c'est tout un nom des pogos si c'est pas
possible
non j'ai pas je regarde n'est pas la
première page switcher que premières
pages numéro 3 et où on était quand même
700 de nouveau en espagne tout le temps
du monde en fait donc le choix que les
raids
ce rythme fou tu en fais vraiment
étonnant d'avoir taxes qui sont
quotidiens réseau s'est réjoui c'est le
fondateur en fait du coup elles sont
avec son étalon prononcé lâchant que la
tam et gars qui m'a mis un coup un
commentaire très marrant en fait le mec
est un mec et hispaniques
bah oui et du oui ce serait marrant
c'est pareil tu commentes mais moi ça
fait genre tongs maillot de bain
coiffant ses portes à paris quand tu
parle espagnol c'est juste un trésor de
ces commentaires il serait drôle et
adore ces derniers devant jeudi maillot
de bain tongs quoi jésus quoi en fait
ces commentaires des chèques de traîtres
au niveau quoi c'est fou tu sens la
pédagogie quoi même on est on est
multilingue
quand même très très fort on arrive à de
commenter un match en espagnol la girafe
un matelot niveau quoi 5 dont la ffu et
3 tu vois bon bah on repart et à tours
il est saoul alors ya encore une info
voilà c'est le tchad des dauphins tout
le temps quand ils ont très très peur du
coup faut que tu faut que tu les envoies
sur ces trappes châtenades fantastique
elles sont chaudes je pense que je fasse
un snapshot de saut avec son chat mais
en général il faut que je la trouve plus
dans mais j'ai déjà un compte des
chances ou de l'utiliser à fond que le
jeu parce que de la merde dessus quoi
capter trois tables d'appoint ce temps
je ne sais pas mais je peux te dire que
mes élèves qui sont les plus jeunes ils
sont que sur ce match attend ils m'ont
dit que facebook c'était pour les vieux
et les jeunes auteurs twitter aussi
envie à tout jamais c'est de la merde
du coup le prix que l'on dit on est sûr
chap soit parce que vous n'y êtes pas
c'est à dire que nous quand on va
arriver sur staff la trouve plus
personne n'y croyait barry bonds
ducousso il est quand même un peu mieux
la cause du pion c5 n'en foutent
recasement pions sur cases noires
lachance loi les tongs mis à bahia d'or
ouais mais bon est ce que c'est si grave
mais c'est une position assez sot est ce
qu'un exactement un petit à petit c'est
de monter dans ton avantage sans trop de
risques mais c'est qu'ici hier il s'est
passé un truc incroyable pendant les
playoffs de la reina mais fantastique en
fait les gens ne pouvaient plus sur le
tchat mantha meilleur premier tour ils
jouent contre avec 1700 bullet
ouais bon là tu te dis le mec va envoyer
alors non il en a rien à [ __ ]
il te fait française ils se prennent
vraiment d'échangé tout le truc le plus
insipide du monde dans les mac et 1700
certes il doit être sais pas mais il est
enfin bon j'ai rien contre les 10700
mais par rapport à meilleur il est nul
donc d'accord avec tes chances toutes
les pièces et pendant une finale de
cavalli complètement égal avec cavaliers
cinq pions contre calais 5 pions de
cavaliers il joue juste ou tempo le mec
il reste 25 secondes contre 15 il le
fait tomber le beau jeu est en fait
toutes les parties il a fait ça donc
j'ai été 10 700 il a tout le temps
égalisé s'est toujours fait tomber mais
en fait juste enfin je sais pas tu peux
me contacter et 1700 c'est des playoffs
fâchez pas à nous on était cette censure
sur le stream bitstream il ya quatre
mille huit cents personnes sur le stream
tu vas officiel pas le mec et 10 700
voix n'ont absolument rien à [ __ ] et
du coup je me dis tu imagines le match
sow meilleur ou [ __ ] mais se serait
déchiré en fait ils seraient des fonds
c'est vrai il serait même des sceaux
fait bah c'est un jeu de mots par sony
ne marchait pas mais j'étais partie gelé
plus choix femmes lancée mais je vous
imagine le match de merde [ __ ] tu es
là tu regardes tu te dis pas une partie
de jeu de 15 coups mais les mecs sont
habillés en noir qu'est ce qui se passe
me branche voyage au bout de l'ennui
mais déjà meilleur dominguez
moi j'avais un peu regardé fallait
s'accrocher
je sais que j'ai le passionnait n'en
fallait être masochiste à civaux la fab
même la 7e
j'ai aussi écouté une interview de tout
mac offre d'ailleurs twitter bastille
une interview en russe voyait très
énervé des échecs ukrainien il te dis
qu'il ya aucune relève que c'est
complètement de la merde et que et qu'il
avait déjà dit enfin j'ai l'impression
de t'ecouter paillis oui j'ai dit à 6 en
2011 quand j'ai quitté le poste chez
plus qu'à l'année il fallait miser sur
les jeunes machin ça n'a jamais été fait
tous nos bons joueurs se sont barrés
nishnic bortnik et comment s'appelle est
gérée bourg machin c'est n'importe quoi
mettre les jeunes qui y vivent ont déjà
la génération qui avait un temps n'a
plus aucun espoir ils sont nuls donc
déjà on y entraîne ses refus arrière
monde où on voudrait vous n'êtes pas
2006 à à 20 ans un train thur vous ne
servent à rien vous êtes nuls déjà le
sel sert à rien mais fera jamais joué
bon bah c'est fait c'est fini donc faut
commencer avec les jeunes qui ont 16 ans
ou du mc alger le chef chaîne qu ils
vont déjà ferme-la l'interview dégage
bon bah il n'a pas 20 ans déjà je ne
parlais pas de lui donc tu dégages
d'après des gammes très sceptique sais
pas quel âge il a mis la tête 18 ans et
peut-être 25,50 tu vois où juste pas à
regarder mais c'est fou mais enfin tu ne
sais pas jouer quoi tu es nul et oui mon
pourquoi vous avez choisi le bélarus
toutes les fédérations vous veulent tout
le monde veut tu as quand même entraîné
saut et puisque tu as et un rapport avec
soquem c'est long et chaud et de caruana
donc tu vois je fais des recherches
avant les matchs fait très attention
et donc là le mec il te dis non j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] je suis en biélorussie ce
très très bien fin mai le mais comprend
pas quoi mais c'est mieux réussi que les
états unis dégage ça ne m'intéresse pas
mais très intéressant fait tout mac os
écrit j'ai pas mal joué mais ça m'étonne
pas vraiment et puis il a l'air sympa tu
vas faire un bon petit soviétique
tranquillement moustache et tous ces
coups de fouet
ouais j'ai bien aimé sa moustache
tu sens la classe absolue du mec les
mecs à moustache su s'effacer
je veux faire un échec pour envie tu
m'as me 70 quand une bonne micro mais
heidfeld au feq
j'ai montré la cave donc je prends une
photo de l'enlever cieux
mais je peux le voir la came bon enfin
je préférerais un trophée est quand même
bien savent que fut la cas mendiants il
fait enfin tu vois je mais oui non mais
donc c'était sympa ces interviews elle
dure 12 10 12 minutes
j'avais 13 et noir et pommes ouais mais
non mais tranquille en fait pas un genre
s'est il énervé mais on paie en même
temps tu as un énervement apaisé c'est
vrai ferme-la cas ça ne m'intéresse pas
vous êtes nuls et les mecs nus et
comment que faire que vous revenez en
ukraine
les mecs sénateurs annonce ilie balaci
fait tout ce que j'ai dit en 2011 je
reviens donc tu dégages toute la
génération qui entraîne les jeunes de
machin enfin il revient ou pas enfin il
ne sait pas c'est enfin si tu veux me
parler tu vois c'est juste une entrée
potentiellement il
il peut revenir ce moment-là peut-être
mais on ne sait pas aïe ne sais pas et
l'interview étant rue soit mais bien sûr
automatique et les échecs quand tu parle
pas russe est un handicap et quand même
c'est pas facile mais
du coup non en fait ça me faisait marrer
parce que tu ai parlé un peu comme toi
mon taf au faut donner la chance aux
jeunes et là nous on s'en fout même si
on réussit pas une olympiade ou deux par
là de façon à des joueurs vieillissants
et white ont dit aussi ne peuvent pas
être mis en danger par les autres dont
il joue trop tranquille et dicky pomme
et l'ukraine ont peu accès pop
non mais dis qui peut les remplacer en
fait la personne
il dit que c'est un problème il faut
qu'ils sentent qu'ils peuvent être
remplacés qui sont pas irremplaçable et
que face et les trucs du club
bah c'est pas un camp de vacances
comment faut il te dit ça j'aurais dû te
dire quant à toute ma cop qui me disent
ah bah du coup voilà fallait hervé
faille n'était pas très énervé si tu
veux juste y leur crache un peu dessus
quoi gentiment tu vois avec avec la
moustache quoi et qu'est ce qui va et
d'autres on attend ce qui était un truc
intéressant aussi
non mais du coup par rapport à notre
idée est excellent sur les manuels des
machins d'entraînement qui n'a jamais
été fait là tu vois je pense que tu as
tout mc offre on pourra s'adresser à lui
un jour de faire des choses
c'est parti non mais imagine tu prends
tout mccow et vlad par exemple ce qu'il
faut un mec qui traduisent tu fais une
équipe pour faire un manuel images
imagine la tête du manuel quand il est
fini avec toute ma kof
bah c'est pas de la merde krakoff non
non non c'est bien ce truc savaria un
peu plus de gueule que machin tu vois et
du coup au lieu d'investir de l'argent à
court terme latin investis à long terme
srp même si tu as des projets qui
s'arrêtent de 2 voilà deux
d'entraînements de janou quoi au moins
ton truc il est père un toit pendant 30
ans ton truc il est encore de pérenniser
pendant 30 ans ton truc il existe encore
alors que sinon il disparaît directement
par n'y a plus d'argent ce a disparu
alors qu'elle a son truc partout même si
vous avez l'âme au départ puis par la
poubelle il n'aura servi à rien tu es
jeune tu récites a personne qui a percé
le truc où enfin mathias et c'est
vraiment du cac à quoi en gros alors que
la suite mais du tout ma cave dans la
gueule tu aurais laissé aurait failli
perdre et j'ai le droit quand même avant
sur du coût de la qualité des
commentaires là tantôt plus utilitaire
de type new open et qu'elle prend des
trois qui on prenait 3 et 5 3 3 rangées
5 13.14 de votre or c'est ce qui va
faire 4 4 av 5.3 penser qu'à trois des
neuf pays se disent oui nous avons
réussi en une nouvelle nul mais les yeux
du ski très content parce qu'on va être
éduqué il c'est bon j'ai vu résultats
sur youtube et j'ai aussi découvert
m'hammed henniche grâce à cette chaîne
on a accès à des informations
fondamentales quand même ici j'ai pas
comme on fait avec fois pour toutes en
découvrir des trucs qu'on quand même un
sur internet on est quand même fort n'en
femmes
ces désordres recherche mais à chaque
fois on se dit non mais cette fois ci on
a quelques rues le truc le plus con tu
as enfin je rappelle déjà contraint à
découvert papa si tôt on s'est dit
[ __ ] on en train de faire une échappée
là on est seul et en fait on a encore
réussi à creuser quoi c'est fantastique
incroyable non par un c internet c'est
une pépite en vente partout mais à
chaque fois je me dis non mais là il va
bien sûr on va pas retrouver d'autres
c'est pas possible pour moi mais dénis
là je me dis [ __ ] c'est enfin comment
tu peux pas tomber plus bas quoi c'est
pas possible mais je pense qu'on va
trouver un c'est sûr mais non mais là
franchement après le match outre des
bouts de limassol à la chirac il aller
très loin
voilà il est au dessus de tout la chose
qui énervait arrêter de tout échange et
fait des vrais échecs en jeudi il y aura
quand même le match lmv elle n'a qu'à
qui sera à mon avis plus marrant ouais
mais bon d'accord je pense ce moment
groupe random j'espère moi je parle à
leur place tout le temps évident itso ce
sera un match sympa
d'où d'assaut ce sera une opposition de
style ce sera sympa en 2006 au souk al
ici
je joue à qui on peut toujours trouver
pire je sais pas à chaque fois je me dis
c'est pas possible quand même on peut
pas trouver pire et puis finalement
c'est si c'est la magie d'internet
tu trouves toujours pire c'est pas pire
ou mieux enfin c'est des trucs c'est
toujours difficile de savoir à quel
point c'est peut-être un droit et fuite
peut-être non pour commencer pour pas se
faire enfermer le roi là bah ouais je
pense que ne soient enfermés louis assis
si on est tombé sur le prix c'est très
bien mais bon il faut et ploce ces
différences est tous au même c'est moins
drôle quand même les germes moment il
est marrant paris son snack chat je suis
allé voir j'ai eu des vidéos du stade de
momo c'est fantastique c'est encore plus
débile que les vidéos youtube c'est
fantastique je vais avoir un truc c'est
un flash qui a foutu 500 boul sur
ipswich istanbul avec sam
enfin vous fait croire qu'il n'a pas
d'argent aussi tout le temps en fait pas
alors que irazein max c'est sûr je suis
fauchée ouais ça il faut chez elle je
suis ruiné ses façades bien relou à
force et vont cf je veux si je cherche
sur youtube sur la larme à 110 purifiée
par le camp 7e roi des petits disques et
où cette somme n'est pas fou ici
d'ailleurs mais il vous plaît attendez
d'en fermer leurs sénateurs
teresa vais pas y arriver et chopper jeu
par les pompiers qui nous donne un
nouveau un nouveau truc d'aller voir
jacques lanxade juste un truc sérieux je
crois qu'il ya une heure un truc
intéressant c'était de faire quatre pour
forcer la tour à repartir et fouillé
mais qui avec trois champions prend des
cinq cavaliers avant un échec
je pensais ne le rates importante à je
pense qu'à l'heure avançant de le
souligner papa bref faire en sorte de
coup quoi non mais tu fais bien de deux
sur lui ni nous coupe le capitaine
sébastien frey mais je pense avec la
même idée mais quoique peut-être tf1 fr
tout reprendre et 5e en france et 5
était un un jeu avec les pions est fait
je crois que ça gagne bombe à travers un
projet dit est un problème de pions
passé je crois alors qu'est ce qu'on va
chercher party games est complètement
insipide su font des gaffes en temps non
mais tu vois c'est là qu'il est chiant
meilleur en fait ce qu'il a le même s'il
en fait il fait rien tu fait une gaffe
il voit tout de suite et tu perds tu lit
de mort si je regarde et qui a joué pour
nous mais j'aurais paillarse qu'une
renaissance et devant le match qu'en
mettant entre gears et là j'ai du mal
quand même femme waouh
on se marre bien bah oui on rigole bien
mais bon on fait un tué les mecs qui
sont en ivoire d échec sur échec à fond
et où ils doivent se dire parler des
parties après ça va vite
non mais autant il ya des matches où on
était passionnant on a beaucoup parlé
des partis autant qu'un match comme ça
c'est dur quoi surtout qui se balance
beaucoup de tories dans la gueule en
l'espagnol en femme savante ouverte
c'est solide s'était ouverte si bien
revenu à la mode mais hammam el hadj
boucle ça
et c'est pas mal non à tanger pas mis le
chrono il ya personne qui m'a si c'est
en mode résidence tout ça est atteint et
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai le chrono 1 je
crois en fait que c'est que cette merde
j'ai le chrono mais j'ai pas j'ai pas le
bon coup de maître je renvoie en fait
j'ai mon chronomètre qui marchent pas
fab qu'est ce que je fais bon ok on n'a
pas de chrono isidore 53,6 au sort
non c'est bon que j'ai remis l'épaule
qui m'a refait donc angoula 37 ministres
presse si l'on construise ouais tu te
bases sur quelle petite base sur quoi
pour dire ça un beau jeu pas sur les
parties en général tous bondés petite
compensation pour ce option mais avant 4
h 5
on y va pour voir des vrais exec un peu
ah ouais aller lâche toi sur ses épaules
un dépôt doit pas trop hésité à remettre
4 à 5 la can où on aurait joué tempo
même pas réfléchi non mal à faire un
petit fauve et deux tiers
bon appétit j'aurais évidemment vous
fait toujours comme ça tu es foulées de
danse à un truc qui est un beau truc
le vent du sang un peu sur cet échiquier
peut-être reprendre cette dame prend des
cinq d'un projet cinq ou six mois me
ramène de mai mais bon du coup il doit
ramener le cheval en f 7 et u mais il
faut en b2 et tue le match comme il ne
relâche pas mais même si matt passe pas
au pire tu perds fin géré mais bon tu
vois la pub
voilà
vous allez encore en gaz allez on voit à
personne il cumule les idées la tati
doit faire des quatre à quesnoy donne un
petit four b3 phare à suivre mais même
des captures prince est on en a marre l
efama les cages ou comme fable où l'on
mettra pas très bien phu et robin
whitehead un truc quelque part et ce
n'est pas mal madrid prend de court tous
vraiment humain est orange et si ça
l'est
allez les temps en temps on en vend g6
unis veulent mater dati va nous faire
qu'a lieu le 5 mai mais la même case
voilà on dit qu'on est 2000 juste pas si
c'est vrai ou pas dans mes choix de 100
200 et cris de mise en sais rien je sais
pas les 1900 les mythes sur internet
c'est n'importe quoi j'ai complètement à
la rue et que le chat je ne peux rien
bon 2434 5500 dossier comme toujours nos
associations
l'aomi 400 mille cinq cents c'est un peu
la moyenne du speech est c'est quoi ta
petite chanson fait ouais je sais plus
mais je me rappelle de l'air c'est bien
écrit c'est en son nom alors je te
parlais juste se présente et on va te
finir de mettre la configuration des
petites caméras tout ça touche au
domaine
je sais que ça en juger par sa demande
et puis nos trucs très intéressant marie
je retrouverai quoi un truc de rugby je
pense
allez on se bat les mecs parlent et une
petite partie d'attac latule fini comme
me faire une nouveauté il habitait
lorgues une heure j'étais inactif il
vous pose la question est ce que tu es
toujours là et je réponds oui je suis là
à gingerbread il y aura non je suis là
mais bon tu es là non je suis là mais
ouais bon je dis oui je suis magie vous
qu'ils vont envoyer photos mais est ce
que c'est un au fake ou pas à tanger une
photo sur mon téléphone annoncé gilles
ou en fait je dis est ce que c'est un
haut fait quoi bon alors vie dit est ce
que tu vois quelque chose allait boom
d'emprunt f5 lachutois finale battu par
direct mais bon tu t'es lâcher quoi on a
peut-être trouvé trois quand même un
femme
ouais et tout revient et machin allez on
envoie vous prend des quatre wesley et
hourra pour faire tour à 8 watts pour un
fable iii à il n'a pas vu attourath
était forfait
stevens a pas l'air trop mal au genou b3
cela pas mal aussi pour que tu aimes
d'amd qui avait t'il avoir ici n'avaient
rien à voir
l'astra valent aussi simple ce qu'il
s'en va tour 8 sinon on va tout bouffer
bon ben je crois que c'est un rideau
d'eau 95 ce qui les menace
mais c'est surtout près il se retrouve
proche 4 revenir à voir damas est
d'avoir des changes et les foules bon
cela dit je peux l'impressionner ça
marche ça marche quand même cet
impressionnant par sa teinte pression
nous pas toi reste impressionnant pas
tellement
mais je n'aurai peut-être foulée 3 je
pense que faire du congo un terrain
espagnol faudra dire pas tellement de
temps mais vous il faut les trois heures
très bien faut prendre ce livre est
autour de nous et tu commences par faut
prendre 500 qui limite un peu plus quand
il faut prendre 5 en premier mais
peut-on manger si yatenga qui je la
chante i yatenga qui comme ça monsieur c
je ne sais pas mal et on prend hk talent
et je vis ta maman belle au final même
si quand tu feras ton damas est 3 e 2
oui mais oui mais combien mais je te
prendrais je ferais là mais j'ai un
échec
tu vois je me bat là-bas quoi maintenant
tu as ta tension qui lâche là ça serait
tellement beau d'archamps claude dans la
compétition l'année prochaine
pour ces cinq bêtement on voit rien on
est vraiment nul dans une pièce de plus
d'un mais si ce chèque se battre déjà
bien c'est pas mal déjà un mec on est
probablement faire mieux fabing est fou
mais trois échecs de nouveau trois
solutions
je trouve ça il faut je soja d'or en
fait ils sont fous totalement en fait
rien de l'intérieur ne trouve pas comme
ça
matt est d'avis tour cet étang proche 4
mon truc comme ça ne tue plus ouais
très sympa aussi
ce bond de nabeul passe comme une pièce
deux mois trois qui se fait attaquer à
tour en h4 c'est une chance que la un
phare bouffe du coût des coûts plus de
no way pas se boucher de l'hôpital mais
mon saut il vient sérieux quand même
bien que son répertoire
j'ai pas quel point ils balancent des
nouveautés ou pas mais je les reprendrai
qu'il vient pas à la mamé quoi n'indique
le bon dieu se rechargeant pioneer la
partie pour il avait gagné ça l'accord
ou parce qu'ils étaient revenus à ses
fins de cycle
il sait qu'à tout révèle assez d'être
enfermés laisser ces jeux là vous aurez
donc pour i 2 août à leurs noms mais
vous êtes vont mesurer
on espère pour lui sinon voilà attend un
deuxième temps dans mes cheveux se faire
tour des huit ces mêmes partir je sais
plus le jeu au sol si je crois bien que
les fassis y avait eu cinq frères et
pensait f3 la terrifie chef 3 longtemps
déjà il veut repenser à f3 de partout
quoi match fc 5e foulées de tours d2 on
avait dit ça on avait l'impression que
les morts étaient très bien non
écoute le genre x mas et une rediffusion
et qui met un petit cas pas quoi mais
c'est ça en fait ils réfléchissent au
même moment et c'est fou bandaï effet
requis si je vous donne aux assureurs va
ils sont obligés par moi j'aime bien
yacine bolt c'est un peu comme si de
gaulle japon m c'est le champion reste
champion ferment tu es tu dois de tu
dois tu dois battre le champion quoi
pour devenir champion c'est un peu comme
comme sur france 2 kw à taïz et en
dehors des recettes à 7,7 et me tiens je
ne sais pas comment je n'ai pas la télé
donc je ne sais pas mais la dernière
news tu as tu sais pas je reviens tous
nos contrats pleuvent ben tu as que toi
tu veut prendre sa place
bon je trouvais le jouer ce genre truc
nous conte sa place in spite ça existe
sur le tchat
il ya 5 heures battu par john jackson
qui des championnes marie-christine
sauve sa place de justesse
c'est fantastique sans victoire la plus
grande championne de tout comme sa place
s'est incliné mardi 9 août au rwanda en
plein dans l'actualité passée
aujourd'hui sa légende genre de tacle
pierre yves michaud qui arrive chez
darty on la pensait indétrônable
malheureusement personne est un terrible
et marie christine a atteint les limites
ses limites ce mardi midi
la recordwoman de l'émission de nagui
tous ne prendre sa place en effet chuté
sur un thème sportif avait ça c'est dur
forcément index et des vraies questions
alors ne parle plus de moyenâgeux
je sais pas c'est l'histoire opportune
sens auxerre victoire victoire
dommage la série médicale à bord
nouvelle vision n'a pas réussi à mettre
aussi tu leur as battu je pense puisque
c'est sur le quinze de france que portal
questionnaire de culture générale il
était fatal c'est un vestiaire rend
facile croyez vous tandis que les
amérindiens eux ont porté chance à un
adversaire pire ils ont été malins ils
ont été décimées et rateront qui a
remporté la finale 20 points à 15 sur un
dock de brest a pourtant donné beaucoup
de réponses cash au bluff de son propre
aveu et du coup marie christine a
proposé huit mille euros sur sa cagnotte
de 162 700 à son concurrent iliad il
faut je sais pas ça s'ajoute à la
coquette somme de 2000 euros déjà acquis
avec ses 20 points et il n'a pas dit non
donc il a accepté à longages championnat
reste ouais mais du coup l'été record
est battu
antoine un bon montant c ces rentrées
ont une position on avait analysé en
fait avant qu'on ait parlé de cette
variante fab qu'il paraissait mieux pour
les blancs qu'est-ce qu'il a joué en
fait mes armes libye coûte estime que
oui je veux améliorer
ouais c'est vrai ce tour des huit
matches et il veut faire tourner c'est
tellement cheval et cette année vont
céder rambi stream donc elles vont
automatiquement fait comme l'anc qui dit
qui a amélioré le grand roque du jeu que
derrick bird terroir fuite entre ses
pieds de vie des autres a failli pleurer
mais ça tourne pour ses 80 ans et 17 ans
s'échauffent avant mais ce serait bien
pour pour le pour le spectacle que
visite remonte de ne pas y faire que
lorsque c'est possible qu'un joueur est
chiche sur 40 secondes
quarté + danse après paris lille encore
retarder ou s'arrêtent en partie lente à
1h30 ou 2h pour réfléchir un truc
facilement je me suis un quart d'heure à
jouer c'est cuit je m'en suis à tout ça
mais surtour détroit ya peut-être vous
prendrez six femmes chiant je lâche une
info échec en étroite possible kessé g7
ont effectué prince est bon avant le
qualifie d' tu peux faire les deux
véritables deux suggestions
bave connecte toi quand même vite austry
ma vie dit pour savoir ce que tu dois
jouer coiffa il se dit est-ce que je
suis fabien ou est-ce que je suis kevin
tu vois il en sueur et là ils
réfléchiront voiture il se recule un peu
de sa chaise saisi lequel des deux il va
peut-être des vitesses ni l'un ni
l'autre aux faucons jeu 5
non non il a fait des petits gestes de
main comme s'il faisait plus floue ce
sera toi que je choisirais tu as si on
est sur toi mais il réfléchit [ __ ]
merde
que faire après le pouvoir cette fois je
te le show actua fou bonjour il a dit
quoi fois juste à temps peut-être c'est
ici qu'ils allaient rendent écouter
vraiment d'écouter d'être la souris
c'est fou mais c'est chaque ça me fait
chier non mais là c'est foutu tout ouais
mais c'est bien en fait visite très
intelligente mais retournera même
variante il regarde le stream
l'industrie mais son suiveur dégage avec
ta cabane de merde avec les noirs sont
chaque d'affaires qui fait le chat parti
au clash et la nuit venue
qui donc on m'expliquer ce que sont des
joueurs pros vrai séjour trop le wes les
sauces et des divers en duo je sais pas
à 8e pas 8 et ouais mais toi et aux
visites durent indien 140e mondial et ça
donc c'est des matchs sur internet c'est
un tableau commun qui dise que c'est des
quarts de finale mais voilà le tableau
comment s'amuser
ouais ben bongo un artiste débutant
si la confiture vous servant de merde
avec les noirs aussi que les deux
partout il ya toutes ces mères du a tout
gagné comme c'est génial
condé pour visite en fait comment sont
choisis les joueurs à y sont invités moi
ils m'ont pas invité par exemple qui
décide les habitations c'est pas nouveau
ban a redit ce qui sera invité à l'année
prochaine
apparemment c'est mal c'est une info que
j'ai un
je n'aime pas ces règles il en a parlé
dans un live donc que camille gagne les
arénas du pense du coup ils demandent je
voudrais voir ce qu'il fait montre le
top mondial est très intéressé en fait
orange il va se faire défoncer super
génial qui écrit la même chose qui va se
faire défoncer même phrase propre clé
dans l'esprit super clean donc est ce
que quelqu'un a déjà joué alors ce que
j'ai déjà joué contre lui m'a défoncé
vie dit non mais généralement contre les
joueurs indiens sont ici plutôt pas mal
fabrice armand parce que tu vas j'avais
fait un match épique contre harry
krishna oui mais j'avais perdu un set au
chic et 1 passe à xian gelé battu bon
lui oui mais arich là j'avais fait
j'avais perdu 6 et demi trois et demi tu
as à l'époque où ils étaient 27 30 quoi
le duo plein nez et tu vas genre là
l'aréna même lundi vendredi et tout un
il ya un mec un en dire assez fort sur
chaise comme à chaque fois je le bats en
fait fin j'ai pas j'arrive bien compte
du joueur indien en général ces gens qui
marie si bien je pense parce qu'ils ont
un peu le même style qu'on que moi je
n'arrivais plus mais
et donc jugé qu'il serait peut-être même
fier que mieux fait que où je pensais
c'est pas mais probable
talent juridique tard au disque et un
classement de ouf parce qu'ils jouent
beaucoup en ligne mais c'est clair qu'il
n'est pas au niveau de heaven nacarat
mais c'est sûr c'est sur ces reines je
sais pas qui c'est fait il ya une
question très intéressante on que pour
wrench de jeunes distribuent ses parfums
ok mais je pense il aime bien en fait il
suivait la chaîne en anglais à l'époque
french visant à y regarder quoi fin
c'était intéressant mais du coup en
français je suis pas enfin je pense pas
qu'il parle pas français déjà cette
pollution ces visites qui s'en sort
mieux un an c'est là que dans la
précédente c'était vraiment fait marcher
dessus n'en ouais mais bon c'est pas
sorti d'affaires la tour sombre un peu
rock un peu faible jambes et on peut
envoyer un peu je sais pas c'est mieux
que la précédente
ça c'est sûr
la censure d'un courant qui vous
conseille de faire quoi passer le niveau
débutant intermédiaire 20 prend le
prends l'abonnement or sur czech comme
vous avez pensé le conseil qu'on peut te
lâcher fab est ce que tu là je te
conseille de te dire une très bonne idée
j'ai touché bel exercice mais en
concentrant tu réfléchis bien avant de
les faire et où pas jouer tempo les
sacrifices quoi aurons-nous redemande
encore qui joue un coup tu as tu as
affaire à une compétition sur internet
un petit peu en championnat du monde
internet officieux un fab
voilà les deux dernières éditions
d'ailleurs été gagné par magnus carlsen
champion du monde d'échecs est donc là
tu as à faire au numéro huit mondial bat
au dessus de moi ouest gso et réfléchie
et un joueur autour de la 40e place
mondiale
visite mais bon qui s'est qualifié en
quarts de finale visite guidée michi
votre très bien présenté travail mais
bon c'était court quoi c'était faux
c'était la présentation express c'est un
peu le fast food de la présentation des
joueurs
bon mais son malheur d'être tellement
dégoûté d'être là en fait c'est très
étrange jamais libre et expressif je
suis pas est-ce que sa copine à la
larguer qu'est ce qui se passe on ne
sait pas ouais c'est ça je t'aime 20
points par victoire de berdych sont les
héros bien sûr la défaite concédée à la
défaite leur apporte deux points quand
vous bon écoute le pion il va l'arrêter
avec le fou attention au roi blanc un
fait qui peut lui aussi être en danger à
tout moment je prends h-2a collège avait
complètement
bah ouais mais bon ça ça peut arriver un
mois mais tu vas pas l'air d'être au
mais je retourne voir venir c'est pas
tout il ya les potes de sow qui
s'amusent à coacher pour son analyse
visite des cas après je pense que là on
est en plein après midi aux etats unis
un fable donc il y aura le temps de
célébrer ses 25 ans 25 ans c'est un bel
âge un fab d'un ménage sauvage mais je
sais pas parce qu'un grand fêtard n'ont
plus qu'un mot si on ne s'est pas autant
tu te retrouves dans un strip club à 3h
du mat complètement pété je vais arrêter
là catalan
je vais arrêter là catalan j'en peux
plus y en a marre voulait donc pour est
très très chaud quoi tu vois bon
lendemain matin il se réveille non je ne
pensais pas vraiment ce que j'avais vu
ça sur b6 vous prendrez si je te mets du
couloir fait attention
c'est génial les trois valeurs
constituant les ventes les plus simples
possibles cgm ccbbo des commentaires des
chèques comme ça c'est la mesure h3g vie
que matt du couloir quoi vous vous
tuerez l'arachide et trimbach je me
savais qu'on s'attarde comme pour chaque
type étudiants la cadence c'est pas en
deux parties sans nom de temps et une
heure trente de salah de cinq minutes
une heure de trois minutes et trente
minutes de bullet minutes chacun ah
ouais ouais ya beaucoup de fric en jeu
il ya bien plusieurs milliers de dollars
en joli ton chez plus je crois qu'au
deuxième tour il ya plus en est
peut-être 3000 ou 4000 ans je sais pas
ça mais il ya beaucoup d'argent enfin
boulanger le fait que tu passes
je suis tu reprendras autour de preah
vihear prendre du fric
beaucoup trop d'argent que personne
fabien sur la chaîne bitstream et
malheureusement je peux pas le dire
parce que c'est ce n'est pas le truc
bitstream et j'ai entendu le petit sont
que je peux pas enlever normalement donc
merci oui d'accord mais ses coûts tu es
sur la chaîne chaise comme ne t'a pas de
toi t'as que le petit sont surtout tout
tout tout tout tout tout pronostic
essai du pack cd best of quoi je sais
pas qui c'est dhayani qu humainement il
mais bon je préfère la musique de type i
bon du coup fab fois cinq tons fou
claude tadam
il se passe quoi on ne sait pas bah ils
ont retrouvé du coup visite faut qu'ils
organisent ahmat m
comment faire je ne sais pas parce que
tant que tu contrôles la cazotte tout va
bien tu peux faire des fouets f2 dames 1
il faut juste croire à la fin mai
l'instance à bombay
pour le moment il a mené 4
je vais changer les dames word up bonzi
échanges construction des gares demande
c'est par un os d'organismes ça une
bonne gueule en tout cas puisque le pion
comment tu l'arête ça on ne sait pas
adepte de fer fois cette fougue et vite
c'est pas une bonne gueule peut-être
faut faire vite surtout
en fait la plus belle des fous est si
puissant technique perdu sa mairie qu'un
intérêt ce qu'il a fait ne fait pas foi
cette foulée de 28 ans tu as trouvé ta
d'assurance a permis mais peut-être tour
un tour à 8 en fait at on pu donner ce
moment là que ça ça s'appelle sauver que
ça paraît un peu compromis mais bon il
se barre en fout moi j'aurais du mal à
gagner ça je pense contre lui pas simple
à temps et ce qui restera beaucoup de
parties ont servi il reste dix minutes à
pied théoriquement il va rester une
voire deux parties maximum dans la
cadence après fab un bouton reverdir
je sais pas
je pensais pas qu'ils échangent les
pions tu vois mais il fait un joueur de
zoug zinc
voilà on va attaquer dès 3 ans attaqué à
quatre dans la poule j ai un mais si
deschamps rêve contre gc nul mfoulou
j'en fais des ciseaux de fougères chose
de très bien elle a fait tomber remède
plus intéressant attention visites
furent écrire au score avec les blancs
foule à se hisser du hockey ce que je
rejoue cette variante de 25 ou je viens
de perdre ça peut être passionnant
fonctionnement très solide ça c'est vrai
ces cinq mois qu'on peut prendre ou pc
si ces deux là je prenais pas fan mais
je crois que c'était ce qu'il y avait
dans la première ronde du match car
c'est la norme deux premiers même séance
plombée 3 reçoit il sait pas
[Musique]
on ne sait pas moi mon pote pour ces
huit mois c'est le temps du sas à peu
près également sa reine montrond joue
six intéressant femme il cloue
historiens sm4 que 0,6 qui visitent
georges super rapidement mais ce qu'il
ya c'est m de temps chacun bah oui tu as
des petites horloges la télé des noms
des joueurs mais c'est le temps qu'ils
ont pour jouer la partie turque chi plus
tu as perdu autant suffire réfléchit
moins ça dépend de la position tu peux
quand même perdre on est encore du temps
assez souvent le cas d'air dont tu peut
être qu'on appelle échec et mat fab
il faut le dire mais du coup à nos
jeunes soient jusqu'à l'aube l'aigle
enfin oui non certes et captura partie
car c'est assez stressé et il ya
peut-être la place pour faire mieux que
hollande
il est d une rapide puis au prestigieux
perdre pied prester fini mais non toute
la partie le tantad c'est une autre
c'est ici viennent car ça n'a fait une
gaffe
de même les droits et il y avait un truc
pour gagner d'options du coup il a perdu
deux matches après quoi
enfin ça continue évoluer ces partis fab
bah ouais je trouve qu'ils font rage 6
dans le cloud il se décale hippiques
what a provoqué a provoqué de trois maïs
coûte à la case d3 pour un quart est
allé voir un fou mais j'aime
actuellement toujours ainsi cgm c'est
d'un grand maître c'est pas pour ça
raconte et c'est juste un titre i'll
échec ceinture noire au judo ce camion
pour se la raconter mais ils sont ils
sont plus forts que moi ces gens
la demande a vu qu'ils avaient loupé le
gain juste après avoir joué le son coût
emprunt serait personnes avaient aussi
bien ce que je dis c'est quoi tu pas
faire plus simple
non je les fais surprendre cinq tours
prend des deux n'était pas obligé de
prendre 5 tu veux revenir en c3 pas
mieux à revenir vers ses 5 vers détroit
n'ont eu cinq et m6
[Musique]
attention quand même super génial je lis
les tulipes ont fait très attention de
te bannir du chat parce que fabien
grands maîtres comme les joueurs mais il
est beaucoup moins fort mais il n'a pas
tort il s'agit à côté on te taquine
c'est fini que musicali chantier ouais
c'est déjà ce que tu as été heureux
quant à lui son nom alors magna quoi tu
le connais ouais moi je pense forcément
à notre sortie d'une barbe pas leur
charge un qui ont vu je suis moins fort
que toi n c'est pas faux c'est pas faux
tu as encore tunnels peuvent encore
finir est vraiment nulle quoi nul nul
nul ne sait pas jouer
fais attention s'étend du fab cette
partie le fond ces quatre qui est cloué
ce serait quand même pas mal femme que
vie dit la gagnante je te le dis tout de
suite fab 2 quad seul fait qu'un bref
ces quatre les clous et donc c'est tendu
quoi bon après tout genre et saint-cast
à zone défendre kung fu cette espèce de
maïs voilà null null null wave 1 tab et
5 mais bon c'est parce que ce fouillé
pas besoin car tu t'y vas pas dans la
position des noirs alors ça va au pire
tueur perception et puis tu te fais nul
non tu sais pas j'ai un pressentiment
dans province accueillir en option je
prends dans d'étroits ou faire un truc
mais je la sens pas bien fab débris pour
les noirs un choix pour moi ce soap
kisiwa stesso première noisette a gagné
un grand faim grande chaise tour et
c'est la vérité les avis ce dernier aime
la paix avec une plus petite est il
courait pour fuste si c'était mon débit
ce momebt quoi c'est génial une planète
non mais tu as raison ça va faire nul on
se tient le plus probable le problème
est en fait les noirs sont vieux jeu
gens vont fusil d'épaulé je pense que
cette série 5 avec les blancs dommage
j'aurai des succès d'une vente de nude
gt3 j'ai cru dame prend à cette dame
preuve de dame prend b6 même si oui
peut-être qu'avec quatre ans parce
qu'ils doivent les garder chaque mais
vous assure j'ai prends je fais dame
prend h4 et je te fais perpète je suis
très content de rentrer de new dawn et
quatre échelles
parcequ'elle plus fort c'est son mba
paix c'est pourquoi il fait page 5
femmes je pense que mbappé court plus
vite que sow avoir et on ferme une femme
mais ça dépend si leurs fans partir
cette cadence ou pas sinon je roulais à
6,55 donc s'il veut refaire une partie
fabre ou qu'ils se dépêchent de faire
nul bon connaissant ce soit à mon avis
de 800 points et l'huile al'avantage non
ça ne m'intéresse pas de d'augmenter non
je pense qu'il n'est pas passionné par
l'augmentation du score non non vous
devez gagner le match
un pragmatique maintenant que ça se
saurait mais tu vas récupérer à b6 bah
oui mais bon pourquoi refusé d'annuler
deux coups pour faire ça quand même
mais là c'est à juste eu aucune chance
oui tu fait qu'ouvrir le temps mais du
coup sony va faire du monde vivent en
train de séduire mais je peux faire nul
tu peux réfléchir bonnes minutes
[Musique]
merci tu vas faire dans ce gène il fait
semblant de
c'est génial mais qu'est-ce qui peut
calculer en position mais je pense qu'il
est sûre je crois qu'il adore à ce genre
de position est calculé ok mais il n'y a
plus rien à calculer que les très
heureux ah oui je peux faire un nul
comme ça je peux faire mieux comme ça et
encore une troisième nul coiffe ou non
mais là il fait semblant de réfléchir
pour pour les citoyens c'est pas
possible
ce qu'il a l'air très énervé en fait
carrière à un truc qui marchait pas et
les quelques avec ses doigts échec échec
ben brik est ce que quelqu'un essaie va
n'a pas de chance et red 5 secondes
je sais que les aider dans la cour du
vacher pas est-ce que ça va rejoindre
bien peut-être qu'ils ont arrêtés mais
restait 10 secondes normalement mais
elle y réfléchit
qu'est ce que j'ai raté donc et les
coachs pour la petite pause autant
printemps poste et puis je reviens par
équipes aux jeux garde les gens en
haleine quoi tu me coupe le son bail sur
son talent et tensions et coupons mais
on n'entend plus d'un band fr qui disent
qu'à l'escroc se sont on ne la fait pas
à moi il a juste voulu gagner du temps
mais je pense pareil que bombardier f
buzz d'affaires ou excuse moi si je
prononce mal ton pseudo
mon cher bah du coup je ne peux pas lire
ton pseudo parlera par peur de mal le
prononcer ouais non mais ça fait partie
du jeu on gagne du temps fait ce qu'il
veut mais bon c'est un peu insipide
bon allez tonton militants sueur mené de
deux points face à un joueur plus fort
que lui
mais il sait pas autant dominé que
j'aurais pu penser personnellement
il ya des nouveaux qui arrivent jean
barbe blanche jean barbe blanche
jean barbe blanche via fléau fléau il
fait coucou
ça lui fait aux visites en sueur sea
dogs kill it20 techniquement soit les
joues et blanc après c'est pas
avantageux pour lui d'en rejouer une
vache moi qui redouble ans quand même là
en fait je pensais en chêne blanc noir
tout le temps en fait j'en vins blancs
qui est très très contents des gens qui
disent bonjour pas du coup mais aussi je
te dis bonjour bonjour à charlo pops
charlypop et là ils marchent sur le
tchat
on saura gogol deuxième bas il est là
aussi dit bonjour aussi donc il marche
sur tout le monde oubliez pas que vous
pouvez suivre la chaîne petit follow le
petit choeur llp quesniaux cora zone et
m
parce qu'on parle espagnol ici faire
quand même très très attention bien dit
chose du cou qui est là aussi petites
choses
bonsoir bonsoir averti bon sens me
fischer boel shirts étaient à la bombe
du coup on va avoir maintenant une heure
de 2,5 plus un bon jour c'est altérer ou
pas n'ont pas perdu ma perruque sur un
quart de finale n'aura pas exagérer pas
de perruque la perruque sera gardé que
pour les grands événements sow qui fou
qui est devant sa caméra quoi il il fait
le show enfin c'est le saut la chambre
que la el bayadh or
lâchant kla il est l'assaut sur va être
bleu fermeture éclair blanche
la combinaison gagnante
il voit un petit peu d'eau très
intéressant tut hydrate
visites y revient pas il a un petit peu
soigné son rhume
pas de réaction un peu plus de ces
expressions je suis au boulot en plus
réunion et je crise où je ne te remercie
pas mais est ce que les autres
comprennent au moins quand tunis où vous
pour eux c'est trop c'est trop grand
quoi aussi sur pie ix où tu as tu peux
le faire aussi comme ça passe à toi de
sentir en fait comment tu l'as achetons
hills où le x ou peut être lâchée de
plusieurs manières différentes de faire
le nid sous ici ils se tuent à tap tap
un tas plusieurs manières de de lâcher
loïs ou quoi après c'est à toi de le
sentir
donc
allez c'est reparti c'est reparti le 4
de wes les boues me 4 de nouveau c'est
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
nothing on you under the sun enfin envie
de dire megan view
est-ce que je rejoue pareil ce qui est
de se faire défoncer quand même deux
fois et il n'a pas forcément très envie
de rejouer la même et j'ai envie de dire
tu as déjà perdu à plusieurs reprises en
fin de reprise
est ce que tu as envie de perdre à trois
reprises d'affilée coiffe enfin après à
toi de voir quoi d'après à toi de voir
du coup c'est un f3 ça bouge un peu j'ai
travers le foot tu arrives à angers 2
sur les taux donc c'est une écossaise un
banquier this
un peu ce que ça donne
bon et si affaires hk 3h deux fois je
crois est ce qu'il a à faire à trois et
six affaires fait 3g cachent quatre
ouvrages de fois je pense complètement
con comme plan une tête hk kg 5
faut être quatre aussi possible tu vas
enfin tu peux faire ça tu peux faire des
trois aussi pourquoi pas tu pouvais
faire ça pour faire sa sphère b36 ben
tanfous en d2 comme ça un jour si tu
voyais cocistes ont tout sera mon
souhait e tu peux faire des trucs quoi
tu peux faire des trucs des 5es jeux
passent jamais évident de jouer ça avec
les blancs parce que de ce pion en cinq
ans fait je sais jamais si c'est
vraiment une force ou une faiblesse
faudrait pouvoir faire si tu peux faire
f4 f5 apsys en fait t'es bien mais si tu
peux pas c'est dur
efficace de il revient
ma femme qui est de retour jérémy la
leçon du conte ou le saut donc à une
lettre près un tueur pareil moi je suis
de retour je voyais ça a joué fab tarn
ils le sont ouais ça relou c'est reparti
qu ils sont à fond je vois ça boume
caïds et 3,6 négociateurs way me existé
n'existe pas top top en fait un pour les
blancs vie si t'as pas l'habitude de
jouer ça c'est chaud nos amis l'ajout
des fois sous maîtrise publique d'état
c'est pas tout à fait son style en fait
je trouve non pas mais il peut jouer
autre chose ça qui s'est mis dans son
style un peu plan-plan qu il ya des
trois sympa après c'est pas très
difficile à voir mais sympa
en ces temps où j'en suis en train de
regarder si les trucs dans le nom c'est
bon j'ai pas fait de conneries succès ce
point qu'on ne sait rien oublier de
faire vos mails et pas mal la vie
d'esclave lecaron detroit il est bien
placé non ouais c'est une pieuvre un
forcément au-dessus mais avec les blancs
jarente structure faut vraiment réussir
à faire le f4 pour moi fkt après f5
peut-être mais c'est important
arman ville souhaite un joueur offensif
dans le coeur faut regarder le showdown
968 la massacrer guiry écoute on
regardera nous sommes médisants fab en
utilisant des feux et phares lignes
phares sais pas c'est pas le style de
jeu enthousiasmant mais c'est efficace
tout cas tout échanger faire nul ou bat
à sont là c'est dur que je prends bien
déjà fait annuler ses biens dont il fait
nil autrement peut-être
franchement en demi-finale contre duda
je pense que tout ça sera favori affable
bon je pense pas non mais j'en sais rien
mais j'aime pas évident mais bon
d'odeurs sur ce qu'il va me rester bien
comme dirait élimine un joueur du top 10
mondial
ça ça te met sur le cul ou pas si quoi
tient une 3 mouais pas un peu quand même
alors dis non ce que c'est que je le
jour tout doucement je sais pas à ben
sahar kasparov quand il jouait donc
voyez à l'équipe un joueur comme ça quoi
moreau shirov je sais pas tu peux en
citer quelques uns parlent pas citer
gandhi pillsbury puisse de riz 1 300
morts fini tout ça on prenne que ce
n'était pas la même résistance en face à
face à résister quand même nom ses
calculs elle veut dire tu auras du mal à
les écraser par amo nordique après
l'ouverture tour de sécher les médias
même style sans il envoyait fait ouais
alors que bon enfin tu vas te battre
c'est pas le joueur auquel tu penserais
plus si tu dis mais qu'envoyer mais il
envoyait mais si j'y peux effet qu ils
te disent à 3 sont en fait que citer
mieux fallait envoyer
sinon on allait perdre son avantage tout
en quoi karoubi petrossian le chat a
acheté les fuites qui avaient fait qu'il
arrive si c'est joli ça
tf6 tu as plus de terreïs je fais trois
des sept noms et qui prend aussi ce
paroxysme bail en fait jour ici je vais
faire roi des six de base et je n'ai pas
vu la différence mais je pense qu'il
s'est planté pareil que moi en fait
de base sur wade si je n'ai qu'à limite
à 5 et ça va et du fus et fait roi celle
ci c'est sûr qu'elle fit en fait il est
prouvé ce qui serait déjà un envoyé pas
mal plus jeune triple effet ben non
c'est dur de voir mais il envoyait
partout tout le temps en plus jeunes ben
tout mbow et en fait ça avec rami qu'un
que tout a commencé à recommencer plus
tôt non mais je rigole pas en plus sa
femme non mais c'est vrai page a rejeté
comme ça non on n'a pas des joueurs car
pauvre qui paraît même écart brest avant
cramique et qui a valu au 5è chômage est
morte avec les 140 mais il voulait
prendre pour château mais non mon fils
de charles est il consécutif effet 5 g
c'est fini bon bien la gagner on se dit
que nul n'était pas mal non
de fait mieux il t'écrase qui n'a pas un
clin d'oeil à réinventer des fossés
chaîne s'était déjà vu passer de tweets
ya 18 ans aujourd'hui des joueuses la
première ronde il a pourri il a compris
le jeu est passé à paulo dans le jazz
louis qui refait du corporatisme je
serai attention pour un boulot ils ne
courront pas la différence entre le
coran ce corporatisme être clivante
écrivent en quoi c'est il me dit non tu
n'es pas qui vend pas moi qu'il faut je
suis client du prix me rebippes où tu
vas donc c'est une discussion un peu tu
as tu leur dis vrai quoi mais du coup on
ne sait plus où elle a changé de ligne
le berceau mais c'est lui qui m'a dit
faut être clivant non non non pas sur
buybuy vous êtres vivants a dit non tu
es du grand artiste je ne sais pas paulo
mais je pense pas que ce genre de chasse
mais l'aurait écrit no way
je pense paulo il aille ou alors il est
dans le chapitre i mas temps de le
regarder parce que si la polo quand même
un fokker on peut agir ça ferait chier
de rater paulo quand même
tu penses que tu en penses sais pas
comment toi tu vois les choses
maintenant cette chambre ça mais je
pense pas qui tu regardes tous bulls
n'ont ils pas peut-être ça lui plaisait
politique ben franchement c'est une
grosse perte quand ils manquent de polo
en tout cas je suis de partout sur son
facebook 1 ces failles ne peut plus
poster un truc sans doute sans avoir un
commentaire fois il est mal rien dit sur
un bang bang
non mais pas encore mais parce que j'ai
vu que tu avais écrit du coup je ne fais
pas le fou mais file à 10 comme tu dis
référence à 100 est complètement con
quoi tu envoies un joueur en prêt quand
il revient il n'a pas deux ans de
contrat il n'a plus qu'à nantes fait des
bises comprend rien au foot comme un
décalage notation va du coup quand sera
football manager paulo tous nous prêtons
un joueur m'a renouvelé son contrat
oui fallait bien qu'ils sont vraiment
très très con quoi de nouveau ils se
sont fait avoir
vous allez comprendre pourquoi personne
au g4 non c'est pas fait une rue que
demande limon c'est une question que je
me pose aussi ce qu'ils vivent là tu
sera bien présent pour mtn la cab on va
écouter écrit ce matin j'ai pas eu de
réponse je m'inquiète un peu tu vois là
parce que normalement il ya censé avoir
tes la vidéo de préparation du truc donc
du coup j'étais complètement la flemme
de la sphère salle en fait un fou quand
d'autres en pdf une vidéo par son niveau
de celle de quoi non mais je vais dit
simple j'ai écrit simple fugue un truc
simple du coup la dila les revenants
c'est trop compliqué sur wii nous ne va
que les l'auditoire moyen n'a pas 2007
fit de moyenne coiffe à varades par
gagner
mais du coup j'ai pas réussi à l'avoir
mais on en arrive là le matin en fait
c'est en fait c'est parce que là les
gens pensent que vlad
il voit à longueur d'année tout mais en
fait bon il ya des périodes où ça peut
être vrai mais sinon c'est un gros
bosseur en fait enfin n'imaginais pas
que vous pouvez être aussi fort que 800
avoir bossé enfin il a bossé beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus que vous tous réunis
je pense en fait ça que tu confirmes bon
je pense qu'à venise et leur tasse et
enfin quand il est en live quand il
avait 18 19 ans il bosse en moyenne
entre 8 et 10 heures par jour tous les
jours quand les échecs pas qui peut
s'asseoir à sa table et dire j'ai autant
bossé que lui mais même aujourd'hui
encore il bosse beaucoup parce qu'ils
connaissent hallucinant ça vient pas
tout seul c'est venir tout seul talibans
une vie navarre ice est à peine bouger
les pièces tout à l'heure et encore
google pour que peuvent prouver siv est
en d2 je pense je pense repartir avec le
fond le cateau
trop prend b2 je voulais tenter avec
vous prend au 3eme mater avec tous ces
mythes
oui mais sommes nous mêmes et vous est
ce que tu te dis prendre un pion le
refuser ses peintures à qui tu es obligé
de te prendre pour ces huit tours des 8
mai les crédits non je ne peux pas en
manger le foin ou trois c'est pas assez
dans l'esprit est bon la partie continue
quoi parler son jeu te faire dame 3 3 je
te des virages future cdc plus dans
l'esprit mike fisher et risques et
chaque escale à reims 1-2 il ya beaucoup
de jeu très bien évident comme le point
de chute
non mais c'est vrai que quand on voit le
style de deux sauts c'est plus le cl de
sauce et le gange la ja fou prend 17
encore au maire est ce que tu as la
gagne et affiné avec un pion de plus
final on est bon quand finalement
surprend message pour ces dames prend 17
reprises prise pris ces cinq prises les
deux prises à cinq noms mode ce tube de
ferme mes pensées nul non ou pas et
inception de l'autre côté et tu gagnes
permanence à la croissance mais déjà 4
ses 1300 ouais c'est beau ce que tu es
en train de dire oui on te conseille
l'abonnement naco alors attends le truc
c'est que vous aurez bien virer le mec
mais en fait du coup comme j'aime nouvel
ordi j'ai pas le comte machin ici et du
coup je vais être obligée d'ouvrir
l'autre ordi pour pour ban powell
lunatique tu veux prendre un abonnement
de chasse comme apprend l'abonnement or
franchement l'abonnement or c'est top
c'est le moins cher et a quasiment
autant que sur les autres
le toc est ressorti que les expressions
des arénas cahier choc
je pense à faire annuler un fab web on
tout dire les dames vivre d'espoir mais
l'espoir fait vivre
lé sport et hop c'est david a bougé 5
ouais je répète les coûts une fois pas
de ça bissau c'est un génie qualité qui
peut bouffer un truc
le g5 moment mais avant c'était
peut-être plus efficace que d'avant
d'ailleurs tu fais pas ton truc
connaissent pas et ne jamais décevoir et
ailleurs il fait mais son choix y est
très heureux là ça y est tu as toujours
la même tête mais plus heureux
janka j'en ai marre si vous avez vu
l'équipe de france très ouverte avec les
noirs
et pas le temps qu'il arrive et
transparent à lille-sud ans si je suis
enchanté les fava et l'ancien nikiya
show tahiti y ait des gens le regardent
mamito regarde joueur agressif genre oui
tous regardent geof
je crois qu'il est obligé d'allumer
l'autre ordi pour pour virer à lunatique
en fait fab ce très possible un brassard
est pas par lui-même il ya des objets de
me faire perdre mon temps mais on peut
être signé très heureux il se dit oui
pourquoi tu me regardes stordis là bas
ce que je dis pas connectés les montrer
tu vois je suis pas bien connecté mais
en fait j'ai mon assistante qui est là
si jamais il ya besoin ils peuvent
apporter leur dit si jamais j'ai une
assistante de choc assistante peut-être
on aura besoin de vous c'est que on va
bientôt la manette xbox y arriva
attention est très intéressant après
demain donc petit pion isolé fab alors
attends faut que tu peux mannella
l'ordinateur parce qu'il faut que je
veux faire des gens non mais c'est
génial il serait hautement débile mais a
prêché très heureux qu'ils aient des
gens tu vois enfin moi je suis en plus
les gens solides you put ça me fait
marrer mais allah je suis obligé de te
suis obligé de te ban mais vraiment
désolé parce que je pense que tu étais
en train de creuser un trou et moi
j'avais envie de voir ça tu as un
sérieux tu me faisais plaisent mais
mais malheureusement je vais être obligé
de tuer est obligé de te ban
ouais je suis désolé je m'excuse eye to
eye on rigole mais malheureusement il a
vu le redis carrier là il se dit en fait
il a peut-être du bol parce que du coup
comme j'avais pas le chat ouvert sur
l'ordi peut-être que je peux pas
récupérer son message et le bon on va
laisser faire un autre message pour voir
le ban mais je sais pas ce qui se passe
à champs sur fable leone m l'autre
quitte donc pourquoi tu as besoin d'un
manager de boxe
pourquoi pas ah mais attends juste en
train de regarder netflix de mettre à
jour avant cet ordi j'ai fini la saison
de better thompson bas et moi je me suis
mis à jour un peu aujourd'hui il reste
moins d'épisodes la fin il s'est
passionné d'histoire secondes bon je
peux quand même je crois que j'étais je
crois que j'ai fini 8 aujourd'hui france
2 mais c'était bien ou pas bon ça avance
gentiment mais c'est une fin de saison
qui en appelle d'autres
oui ça peut être la fin non encore une
ou deux je pense pas beaucoup plus
ah ouais carrément très minces pourquoi
ben hamza je le sens wildfire t'as pas
d'infos c'est non oui vous c'est sûr
qu'on va avoir dix saisons ne s'est pas
servi qu'ils écrivent nos sports oui
enfin on fait ce qu'on veut s'assurer de
spoil juste pas une fin non leurs quatre
autres
mais bon dans la chance que j'avais pas
regardé sinon ça en train de tout dire
moi j'en suis au moment où à l'essentiel
eux ils ont donc fait cette position
solidaire très énervé de nouveau devant
moi je regardais la série élite là qui
importe dans une pointe rocheuse que je
viens et vu cardonnel papeete c'est un
espagnol juge francine série crise ita
se regarde forcément
with ça marche pas mais la seconde on
fausse spoiler mais où il ensuite parce
que vu que banon mais nie g solution tu
vas enfin peut-être timide tête se tend
un piège
non mais ça c'est un verrou c'est un
spin off en fait c'est ce qui se passe
avant avant breaking bad
donc tous les gens qui devraient en bas
ne veut pas mourir dans des torcols sol
on ne sait pas après c'est peut-être un
univers parallèle altered carbone tu
avais regardées moi j'ai regardé j'avais
bien aimé c'était sympa comme ça y est
je préfère je préfère comment s'appelle
à west ward mais pas mal alter de
carbone oui j'ai regardé en 2018 mais
mangent pages et groupes répit dodge
j'ai un oncle mieux je sais plus
pourquoi j'ai pas compris
jamais
bon fabien est quand même mieux vie dit
allez faut scorer là enfin faut se
bouger un peu le fion ils souffrent sera
tiré ce match il souffre il peut
souffrir mais souffre sur avec le
nouveau remix fab il ya un nouveau remix
de x ou bats il souffre sous sa entend
de plus en plus bas c'est génial est-ce
qu'on a un bon bouquin pour les
débutants talenton watson sur les
ouvertures sur regarder mais ce n'est
pas si c'est pas un peu plus fort que
débutant sinon tu peux reprendre les
conseils de fabi du début c'est à dire
comment bape a pas d'échec et peut-être
les vrais la braisière de de tartas
commerce parce que c'est un livre en
français était aussi l famose aux
abonnements aux requêtes points comme
cracher bottes le genre le totalement
débutant ce sont des bons concepts de
base le mont system link zollitsch du
vieux truc tout simple du vieux n'est
pas content oui c'est pas pour dire les
gars met en scène et et rennes se sont
beaucoup plus sérieux de sur le
broadcast en anglais ils font ce qu'ils
veulent ils sont sérieux tant mieux
enfin jeanne on n'est pas contre un si
tu veux être sérieux tu es sérieux ce
n'est pas sérieux ce n'est pas sérieux
faim acf
c'est chacun commandes comme il veut en
faire un phare à 16 matchs et cependant
comme l' avantage c'est que tu as comme
fabien cottin chaud l'avantagé avec
chaises comme c'est que c'est les
audiences qui parle genre si tu es 30 tu
vois même 50 ou même sens tu vas pas
être pris quoi donc en fait ils te
laissent vraiment enfin une chaise comme
tu as vraiment tu vois ta ta vraiment ta
liberté comment tu veux qu as tu es tu
fais ce que tu veux en fait le seul tous
les jours des gens qui regardent certita
personnes qui regardent la sas et
disqualifiants c'est pas un truc publics
ou des copains avec rennes chelito
pouvant tu vois ça tu as d'autres
organisations ça peut marcher comme ça
là c'est différent là mais après dû
coûter plus libre on va pas t'embêter
avec ce que tu dis quoi on te laisse
commenté comme tu veux et tu fais ce que
tu veux quoi
parratt en france 3 qui laissait cat
bonds est tombé six détenus y sont
encore très froid ça marchait qu'avec
fais comme tu es libre franchement de
chasse - comme si la liberté est un
petit pion des 6 et indiennes et nous
plaisir alors placé cinq mois déjà vu ça
recommence les amis même b6 et c la
vérité fabian nul cette ouverture nul
fade vachement sueur ja spam show fait
quoi dans cette partie chauffe toi fab
va te mettre un seau d'eau chaude quoi
fin tu reviens tout rouge off comme
dirait ma femme telle une écrevisse quoi
ça existe à l'expression français ou pas
bonjour une crise
ouais bah ça existe le temps c'est rouge
mais creuse entre les pays c'est pas
beau mois en france en russie comme
ailleurs c'est notre couleur être un peu
gris 74 à glisser moi non mais c'est les
partis qui sont mal enfin c'est mou en
soi même en fait enfin l'heure de
commenter pourront de niveau 1 pour
raviver le débat mal mal et masque est
tombé trois tours en d4
selon mes sources money maître
international no fake dorval au fake
est-ce qu'on peut va faire tour prend b3
à des cavaliers e4 fou prend fou prend
des cartons échanges tout quoi ouais
mais tu aimes soudure moins bien la
famille oui mais moi tu fais enfin tu
t'approches de la nulle
wiz khalifa qu'on ne peut pas être une
photo de mme hier à la place de leurs
cammisar d'enflammer le match très au
dessus gestion je crois qu'on oblige les
canons mais je pense qu'une canne de
millas en train de commenter le match le
plus intéressant mais bizarrement ça
elles font pas autant de vue que ça en
fait c'est idiotes sur sur fond de
fonder live quoi bein emilia ci parce
que c'est mia mais les autres pas tant
que ça en fait du coup de tête on bouffe
ont fait tour d2 on échange on fait nul
on va peut-être pas réussir à faire tes
l'éperon c6 quant à la relance et 6 il
menacera la case de cette tu vois voyez
peut-être mieux avec les blancs invite
même sûrement fab fabrique de broc et
passifs et ses créations peut-être car
il ya cinq ans j'aurais peut-être ce cas
à cinq quand même tu as pour of je me
serais pas jeter sur le pion tu vois
invite yvon option dimanche au new
morning ne remet rien en cause
peut-être car il ya cinq excès de fer à
3 mais le cas est bizarrement est
difficilement attaquable ok mais ni
d'aucun d'entre vous qui est là pour nos
terrains du match aller gagné la gamme
jeudi pour le grand show magique ya 1200
personnes sur le stream résigné mais ils
sont en prison bon damien patch même ils
sont en première page première pas le si
c'est pour ça en fait nous la fois qu'on
n'est pas en première page première page
malheureusement et du coup autant je
vérifie parce que sinon en fait tu en
sûr si on en croit pas ce qu on appelle
des prix moins que les brésiliens les
mecs francs sur non mais les loisirs
c'est un groupe i qua non non on n'est
pas en prière pas de prière par
grignoter mans n'étions plus que les
brésiliens quand on est à armes égales
on y forme isolés ils ont le portugal
avec eux et j'en partage sur les réseaux
de partout nous convions de partage
aujourd'hui par études qui disent non je
veux pas savoir se le dit maintenant tu
m'as demandé il ya tout ce qui rentre en
v2 quand même fable un rôle à tous
rentrer en b2
mais attention ce quelque chose que vous
dirigez par nous-mêmes à nantes et où on
serait pas mal sinon c'est bien
millionnaire catherine frot de chose due
enfin peut-être commenterai aussi du
coup mais enfin avec les photos de
milhas du coup pour la peine marié du
coup j'en serais lancé dans d'autres
commentaires
alors attends attends fab je vais te je
te donner l'info la chaîne info sur la
partie je lâche une info à facebook ok
avec monza je suis un fou c'est que je
te dise que les blancs sont mieux contre
info
il ya eu c'est partage fab à cette fin
j'ai pas envie de près de 2 comparé
écrit brésilien ski à minimum 50 donc je
ne préfère pas me déprimer mais bon
c'est une autre culture
mais la route à beaune top écoute est ce
que vous dites là je suis une info est
ce que vit peut bien c'est parti avec le
plus en plus il peut va-t-il de fer
taxman pâle qui me demande ce que c'est
vrai que v5 sa b3 a pas que je sache
mais bon tu tentes et pourquoi pas mon
époque où il y aurait d'autres sites
feront que les espaces étudiants il a
fait un bras de fer
on va pousser plus fort tu peux proposer
est ce que tu peux imposer buy fait
d'être au dessus des 5 après tu peux
jouer à cinq hommes comme soul ce qui
serait bien ce serait bien ça puis ce
qui te fait à quatre et c'est choquant
par écrit sur la page d'accueil touitou
et on n'est pas sur la première on n'est
pas la première vidéo qui tombe dans
votre attention ça change énormément de
choses en fait d'être premier ou
deuxième
il ya du coup tu te retrouves qu'avec
les gens qui ont vraiment eu veulent
vraiment voir ton contenu tu te
retrouves pas avec les autres qui
passent là par hasard qu'ils cliquent le
cours de l'audience c'est quoi ce truc
c'est ça là on est deuxièmes donc ce
n'est pas trop mal classés plus tu es
loin en fait j'ai en moi hier c'était 3e
4e - ça ça pour toi c'est la famille
c'est apprendre tout à l'heure quand
arrive et là ça a changé dessus situe à
beit
le pet ses revenus ça peut changer tu
passes 1re 2e jean paul influent dit il
partage quand même ça nous fait plaisir
on voit les chiffres tu en es 18 tu
connais en premier de nouveaux femmes
bah du coup ça on n'était pas c'est vrai
mais si on est dépassé par les portugais
serait toile mais sur une radio on est
vraiment deuxième même en fait on s'en
fout mais je me dis c'est faux pour s'en
[ __ ] façon peu importe mais je vais
rétractable comme le dit nico l'affiché
pas super sexy et avec kevin lacasse sa
ferme à deux voyages j'imagine barèges
suis pas sûr femme bien foiré la
personne qui va en parler ni rien il
faudra en partie par exemple partager
publié sept des snapshots et facebook
sont plus jeunes et twitter c'est un
désastre à g et qu'il faut te regarder
ça m'a écouté l'adoption 2000 un pion de
plus mais sa tour et pas très active je
pense que ça va faire d'une femme mais
il peut presser défaut qui gagne la
[Musique]
coupe dodge en une seule histoire où
jack black deux groupes demandent si ces
démons roger je suis très morose en
depuis de vitesse je suis super morose
tu sens la morosité ou pas pourtant on
sent la morosité depuis tout à l'heure
je suis très très triste
enfin parce que ça à faire du loup pas
bah je sais pas voilà ton skyblog
exactement sur msn
c'est chaud femme est très chaud puisque
ces personnes
pourquoi transvasez imprimera contre un
pur h pourquoi pas un truc c'est que
c'est pareil
deschamps
bon enfin peut-être ci peut la gagner
besoin de pions mais s'offre aux
techniques 1
[Musique]
à quel tour 17 quelque chose mais le ton
qu'on ait trouvé à la vitesse de
l'éclair visitant sur sow qui rigole
haidar al hayya rigoler la fonderie qui
s'échauffent avant la 28e catalan du
match je sais pas quoi te dire femmes
n'ont rien d'un écoute je dis rien si tu
veux un si génial on dit plus rien
[Rires]
lassana comptes salue le doigt du futur
qui n'arrive rennes chez machin
s'amusait beaucoup plus c'est ce qui se
cherche
ouais je rigole fall j'ai le droit de le
nord
je crois que ça fait marrer aussi
d'accord chip amf en général bon
sur le futur papa lui répond switch là
que donne c est mieux que leurs voisines
ba s'est passée mieux la même couleur en
même temps tu es vite quoi c'est génial
en fait j'ai passé trois des quatre ans
fin mai ce qu'il vaut mieux jouer une
estonienne une écossaise
ça dépend de l'ordre de coûts ça fait
penser une question c'est un peu comme
les matches qu'est ce qui est mieux les
éléphants c'est quoi les hippopotames
contraire rien contre eux qui ont déjà
latent mais c'est qui qui défend les
crédits à des taux bas les taux bref
mais il ne voyait rien mais trop de
portes s'est pas passé comme je crois
qu'ils échangent tous de nouveaux
savoir-faire rykner et sans ça le fait
marrer qu'il est très heureux
nous sommes avec son 8e sèche beaucoup
dis pas tu répondais pas cette approche
est comme tout le monde est alors mal
non plus je réponds pas à lyon tu peux
en train de chialer pour sa part mais
j'ai sûrement en train de faire le
stream à pédagogique c'est très
pédagogique de tepco comme démagogie
j'ai pas je vais des systèmes de londres
je fais de la merde prophète
j'ai gagné toutes mes parties furent eux
je fais un benko aussi althea qui nous
aussi au lac et tables muchacho je le
petit coucou mari se serait en train de
se marrer ça te fait rire ses positions
ouais ça va ça va merci tu mal de tête
ça va
écoute fab cette partie en ce moment
c'est quand même peut-être la plus belle
partie de la soirée fab on se prépare à
voir des nouveaux échanges de tours va
tous réfléchir alors il peut toujours
être en symétrique c'est un peu la
question qu'on se pose oui donc dans le
stream allemand georg meilleur est en
train de se tailler femme devant cette
partie il partait vraiment très
intéressante avec des échanges de pièces
si je te par macif ouais c'est comment
est intéressant fab
ces échanges de pièces massif fab qu'est
ce que tu en penses
là où ces partis moment où les
attentions
que vas tu aurait changé maintenant j 5
il en explique denis bon à sochaux il
habille leila il a levé les yeux au
séjour qu'est ce que c'est que cette
merde rohff qui sait les opus qu'il a
connu des berlinois plus palpitantes
chasse aux puces qui est là non mais
c'est énorme c'est parti c'est énorme ce
match dans les champs ce sujet très
heureux quand sous candidat va s'en
prendre à sommer ouais tu as raison il
ya peut-être se faire juste sécher en
fait je t'échange tout possible
jouant classique ouais ça arrive mais
bon je sais ce que je peux comme de tous
sa femme il pouvait pas faire tout c'est
un échec et 5 3 mais je n'ai pas fait ça
marchait pas de faire enrager 2 pas
moyen de soutien sur de nouveaux oui je
préfère échanges thijs et 6,60 à sic et
peut-être fait que les dessins qui
essaient c'est toi tu enferme son
cavalier ou quatre qui est des six camps
et tu te bats quoi mais voilà tout je
donnerais tu pas le bloquer en fait ma
petite fille qui sait 3 qui est des cinq
jeux pas tu te bats wef 5 a bien joué
j'ai 4 je veux changer des pions nago il
a fait une focale sur le cavalier quand
même un texte paulo qui vivent en
dessous virus très intéressants dont la
fin tu décides tous les deux donc la
petite répétition la répétition année d
imposition mais la fougue de jeu et
donne tout ce qui peut pas leur visite
le futur qui est contente elle était
trop bien la vidéo en cinq minutes de
blitz cave du maroc hard c'est trop bien
fait ce qu'on peut un tintamarre honneur
ouais la saison longtemps dans les
salles on va mettre un buzzer quoi et
alors enlevé chacun d'aider des pions au
mieux quand il faut que donnait même
truc
le public devrait pouvoir voter on
dégage ce que je tombe sur des 5,7 à
prendre naturel et méthodes soir à
luanda des gars dégagés les joueurs on
veut qu'on veut l'esprit quoi mais en
fait c'était un peu l'objectif des fins
tu as que j'ai pas compris facture - le
moment un peu what the fuck avec 16
points comme tu vois pas ce qu'on peut
un peu discuté aussi tu vas femmes enfin
en fait on ne fait que ça quoique
envoyer les arénas en fait enfin tu
compris un truc que je comprends pas
avec chaises comme honnêtement pas je
suis l'unique 8 c'est que d'un côté en
fait je te dise où il faut qu'ils aient
des streamer qui est des gens qui est du
monde et tout est d'un autre côté en
fait tilt enlève les prix dr streamer
quand tu joues les arénas tu vas tu peux
avoir deux spectateurs sur ton truc tu
joues aussi pour les prix déjà évoqué
donc avant tu vas tu avais le prix du
plus gros streamer à chaque fois c'est
75 dollars c'était quasiment autant que
que la première place on va ça dès
qu'ils ont senti que je m'étais mis sur
twitch et que tu as à monter et qu'on
allait le prendre
ça a été enlevé tout de suite mais je
comprends pas en fait pourquoi t'as
pourquoi d'un côté en fait ils veulent
ils veulent encourager les gros streamer
et machins et les trucs marrants et d'un
autre côté en fait ils vont pas jusqu'au
bout de leurs convictions sur ce qu'ils
ont envie de te dire tu vas trop loin
seba s'était passé sérieux voilà mais
non mais là c'est parce que ces
rencontres m en fait fin frc façon
relâchée sur des chaises bras ou quoi
fin tu as et n'importe qui en fait et je
leur parle en fait c'est gilles mal à
comprendre ce tout le truc tu as de ses
échecs
c'est étrange que l'appareil qu'avec les
deux joues quoi ils pourraient choisir
en début de saison va toi tu n'as pas
que pas assez bon à tampico enfin pas de
chance quoi ce que je redoute c'est que
c'est un peu le sport à l'américain
savent que en nba dans les sports
américains football américain et ce truc
là en gros quand il n'y a plus assez de
spectacles qui se changent les règles
enfin disons qu'ils ont pas chez nous on
fait pas trop ça on a un sport où que le
meilleur gagne et on s'en fout tu vois
mais les américains ont quand même cette
tendance à un moment donné quand le truc
devient trop chiant il ne change les
règles pour les violettes vervins qui ce
n'est que contre toi maintenant face et
par an contre moins assez c'est assez la
logique en fait que je comprends pas ils
se rencontreront à fin mai du coup en
fait le truc de buzzer ou quoi ou tu
vois il pourrait implémenté en fait va
réjouir robe quoi dégage
l'atuge de la grotte maintien je suis
tous les taux de change et des habitants
et des services
tu ne sers à rien tu ne mérites pas tu
ne bat pas de changer les teen wolf pas
trop vite parce qu'il sert les clubs
mais croque est content d'ailleurs pour
julie benz en tout cas insipide
il a repris l'aventage visite mais
lorsque vous dit en fait il n'est pas
loin
1 les joueurs en trois mois mais oui les
mieux moi en génie dont ils ont tant que
pays nous mettre ses mains du soir au
montpied fait cent ans que celle inverse
mais bon je sais pas débat c'est bizarre
je peux à présent ensuite mauvaise
humeur face eu très chaud en fait mais
bon alors qu'anne qui sait quoi veut pas
grand chose en échange des pièces à
foison mais wesley so mène de trois
points
tu prends 2
les joues bref rendu fou je garde mon
fou du système de long tu vas font quoi
tu prêt du tout il bouffe et en dessin
qui va ramener un truc en d6 je prends
tout je fais nul 10 10 le oui non pas
moi je ne m'intéresse plus je prends des
systèmes prend ici ça me prendrait six
avec gagne la fia est faux de croire
oppose et tient au fait tu fais ton même
il faut compter 6 sur les formes du show
sera david adams évite de les fidèles
c'est ça moi je fais un processus
sérieux même si je peux gagner en fait
ça ne m'intéresse pas non mais je crois
tu prends de demain très content
bah écoute fab va francs des 6 1
peut-être le garde encore un peu pour
faire illusion
après deux places se résoudre à prendre
bah écoute il va être résolue à mon avis
non tu ne peux pas faire d'amsterdam h6
vrai mais ça va être dur comme cette
action le 3 qu'un peu sur le chemin
qu'on nous d'autres un jour
on verra bien c'est pas fab
j'en sais rien
fable que dire que faire il va faire fou
des six il va nous forcer les changes il
va même peut-être la gagner soan le dr
sandor web on vous avait dit que c'est
de mauvaise humeur donc maintenant mais
ce que je suis en mauvaise humeur fait
je ne suis pas un réellement mais ce que
tu as cette impression à un bon compte
non mais dis la vérité fsu pense aussi
mais en fait c'est pas le cas mais
peut-être que ça donne cette impression
sur l'inédit le fameux tu en veux dire
que tu es d'accord le sang non je suis
je là survivre quand j'ai mon petit mal
de tête tu vois je suis pas je peux
attaquer je suis ce que je peux je n'ai
pas fait mon jeu pas sorti je n'ai rien
fait c'est juste pas de chance car ait
maigri quoi chasser les grilles tu
critiques tout comme d'hab à moins de 10
ans bah non mais bon enfin faut dire que
c'est pas évident de parler pendant des
heures de ces partis qui sont pas super
intéressant non il est bien obligé de
raconter quelque chose pendant des
heures tu vois je raconte des trucs de
partout j'essaye de parler très vite
aussi mais bon c'est pas évident après 1
je suis va la perdre ainsi nos sites web
mais bon oui je le suis et j'aime bien
faire ce sujet le groupe uni belles
escales en france
mais bon ok il a de la chance car si
c'était encore d'un match 8 rouges et
d'autres films troll un édit que furon
font en fait c'est pas du tout vrai quoi
enfin nos petites choses s'amuse avec
toi le tchad et oui mais ils se foutent
de ma gueule en fait [ __ ] c'est
horrible je veux négatif tu critiques
tout bas mais bon c'est un peu leur
coeur
alors que tu york yacht offre que vous
tue de plus ça ils ont mis en sueur
c'est fini baroque et on ne parle plus
alors c'est fini on dit plus rien quoi
on va regarder des répétitions matin non
mais après je me dis j'ai peut-être
vraiment l'impression démolition au tour
du monde parce que c'est pâques a en
fait je suis en train de me marrer
machin c'est juste que les parties bon
gars c'est dur de vendre du rêve
c'est surtout vendre du rêve mais bon il
ya deux riley mais mon pain que veux-tu
quoi je suis un peu comme cramique pour
toi ça ils totale entre les peuples
merci ces filles qui fera plus de
commentaires c'est fini tu es tellement
au dessus
non mais il veut se placer au dessus de
moi je vais plus conclut je vais tendre
le scrill fait très attention
l es bon tu joues contre un cinquième
dan la cave infiltration famille l'a
compris depuis longtemps
donc maintenant il essaye plus à putte
un enfant je dis plus grand chose si
mais c'est vraiment pour élever le débat
à chaque fois que j'ai des trucs c'est à
dire que tu as le débat et uc pour
élever comme à chaque fois des seuils
plus d'abaisser de débats d'élèves tout
en bon fab voilà cette position bonne
écoute
mepha bas léon feix h3 fou trois dames
des deux ont sacrifié enfin tu vois j'ai
pas mais un peu de vie quoi je crois
pour luter king me fait peur la bo de
faire ça mais fou et trois dames des
deux franchises fab fait chier quoi au
bout d'un moment
non mais voilà mes fins en fait on mais
comment tu vas être heureux en fait
qu'on le mec te fait saddam 2 pouces et
2 mais je sais pas mais ch3 fou 3 machin
tu vois quoi
[Rires]
mais oui on aime bien cette structure en
fait mais pour à l'envoyer fou prend à
six mois que j'ai qui à travers mais non
damée froide mais froid fou prend un
cheese fab
enfin vraiment il ya qui prend 1,5 non
mais il fait chier il à tout va le
placer le nom local à metz 3 m/s trois
ds3 à vas-y
d'un f3 j'en ai marre femme est fou
prend 1,6 direct aller lâche toi [ __ ]
dans les fab fois plus quelque chose
heil offerte à l'idée de rater ici je
reconnais bien là mon petit wesley bonté
ou serveuse il reprend mon flanc au nom
non français 4 td ses faits d'armes
français quatre ans quand même pour
échanger la cua et foutez 323,3 je dois
aller vous savez des fois j'en espérais
allez vous au bar pourquoi changer et
moi dans le roi de la pop très bien
placé voilà allez droit de la drogue a
tout d'un coup c'est semble plus
intéressant pour les bombes c'est un
problème s'ils s'allient avec id tour au
sein quoi à un trait du tout d'échangé
d'un veille sent poindre le danger mais
bon attention à ton plombe les cinq ans
tout le taper dans l'es4 tu prends de
l'espace faut quatre pouces et 6 n'ai pu
gagner ce au sol pendant quelques mois
on a eu un moment de frisson quand une
femme alors du fourrage titre ou
attention son geste est en surcharge là
on était des chevaux bahreïn on
s'échauffe et là tout d'un coup les
poumons soupire on prête il vous faut
six fois f3 double attaque vous faut
bessette notre attaque aussi une fois
6/7 3/6 aussi infâme dossier aussi hills
où il est tombé huit fois f3 aussi
possible tout est possible fable les
visites ils voteront sueur il se mouche
fait quand même alors dit non il
disparaît de la caméra les lits baisse
ouais c'est lé content à mes comptes
duda ça peut passer
il va faire ça il va faire sa duda il va
vous tuer va monter à la volée bon
passing revers boombastic coup droit
boum passing volé je suis à la volée je
te fais un passing quand même des gages
d'un single sommes qu'un petit passing
amorti attendu d'autant qu'on assiste
aussi de linz la puissance de résister à
ce sens par de wesley so dj choc la
boillat fouet trois oscillatoire prend
ainsi à tous ouais le genre de 24 heures
pour dire que c'est bien ouais je pense
puis pour le plus sympa aussi mais oui
pour bruno fait qu est-ce qu en fait la
pression je vous montrais des besoins
quelques nous pouvons changer si c'est
juste pour le geste
bref at&t champagne connaît pas des fois
tu reconnais ton femmes n'ont même pas
si c'est génial de chine je me suis tu
te mets à la volée pour retourner le
service et chaste à droite les mais je
crois que t'as pas le droit de la papa
report de vol à cerner ce n'est pas de
chance que c'est dommage
enfin c'est beau quand même de reprendre
de frein certain que mon vol avec toi
t'as pas de bloquer le stérilisateur en
sautant oui alors que toi ses fins et
pour les trucs que tu as envie de faire
de base
paf je te bloque le tableau qui connaît
ce match à ton service
ce serait beau de retourner service
volée le mec serre et tue le jeu match
direct la pression c'est très puissant
faites pas ce que je sais plus où moins
laval vannes était bien placé tu peux
vite vraiment à du rassemblement il faut
quand même faire ton camp des saints
jardim qui partira de décorer la chambre
de la complète je sais pas il veut
peut-être dire et même leur horoscope
quoi je sais pas peut-être des gens qui
rachetaient là les barons s'est passé
assez barça pouvoir mais ouais mais
jardim par contre c'est plus c'est plus
sûr et je vois ce qu'il s'est passé tout
allait très bien et tout d'un coup en
l'espace de trois 3 semaines à ses
filles bas où tout est très bien les
dangers du prix match contre nantes
non mais au delà de sa jambe chaque
année 7 kg d'équipements tout le monde
genre ça passe pas c'est comme si on
arrête fouet 4 hills ou non mais ça
c'était évident et que ça finirait par
mal se passer mais bon je ne sais pas à
faire un genre tu remets pas en cause
entraîneur il est pas pour grand-chose
cette vente lui tu n'y plus rien que
j'ai gagné romati commis peu à oui je
suis bien et qui est située à des grèves
et je comprends pas en fait le projet à
la chambre c'est faire du fric look est
allergique à la vente à la con mais bon
là de vue c'est une triple riscle a
aussi mis en place à rejouer sa ba oui
je serai jardinage place de cette
chaleur est depuis longtemps et c'est
très bien payé aussi renoncé pas oui et
charmant mais il se rappelle bien pays
ailleurs ce raid a fait ses preuves on
sait que simplement trader parce que je
sais parler des champions quoi le
couteur quand ils font de lui finale la
coupe les juger quitte à l'istp qu'elle
bat p falquerho devant les marc silva
sur textile au mieux et bakayoko
fait fabinho fâchez pas c'était
monstrueux qui sur les haltes et à
benjamin mendy sidibé c'était des
grosses équipes quoi on fait tout pour
faire n'importe quoi après t'as vu
marseille arrivé tu as vu qu'il refuse t
gros ils ont recruté valeur gerber déjà
tu perds germain derrière ils recrutent
mitroglou en attaque
non mais voilà tout cinq top-5 meilleur
potentiel que messi je pense donc donc
là tout de suite après tu es mal quoi
meilleur potentiel d'europe mais pato 20
après donc là c'est futur ballon d'or
et tu sais que tu as plus aucune chance
aux italiens ni rien quoi et du coup tu
tu changes de projets quoi ils sont
restés gros ils ont recruté va être cher
avec sa tête de ben ali ce nul car manu
tu merci francs suisses ont marqué
l'autre jour il était dégoûté quand il
ta marque mythique qu'on attendait ça
depuis si charmant il se réfugie 40
c'est mon fils je vais pas mal à monaco
ça plus drôle c'était pas des
remplaçants j'étais bien voulu rentrer
un peu ouais il y avait même bape et des
fois qu'il joue à côté donc pas si tu
est ce mieux qu litres au bout
faire une nouvelle petite nul attention
piège qu'on fabrique quatre peut-être
que fermer quatre études en asra tour
des trois opus
alors ouais mais il est fort souvent
pour faire ça pendant les fermes puisse
dire c'est que ça paraît un peu
méprisant méprisant à votre servait en
fait c'est vraiment le faire non mais
c'est dur de rien faire aux échecs c'est
très dur en fait c'est un tour de force
un fab est vraiment palpable et je
soulèverai sociaux vient de vivre
c'est le truc le plus dur aux échecs de
savoir ne rien faire ouais c'est plus
dur que faire quelque chose
il m'a dit je suis très bien ne rien
faire son plus grand talent à celle à
qui je dis quoi c'est tout le monde dit
que l'on parle devant gilles non mais il
te dit en fait que c'est comme que c'est
comme jordan quand le plus dur quand tu
sautes au basket c'est de rester en
l'air mais c'est vraiment plus nous
avons rien au foot mais attention je
pense que pour les experts tu es un
expert aussi je fais un brave
sa défense sur catoire laisse alors
n'allez nautico ne l'attiré pas dans
notre chat
enfin the great food l'autre jour là sia
nader je le rappelais plus grands chefs
tribaux il veut peut-être réparer le 4
il faut prend à 5
oui du coup en tête en c6 r on fout des
limites quoi 4 quand même d'être 4 quand
même problème exception et 5 pareil ce
serait trop que je devrais me marc
tissot juste y connaître de morano
l'hélicoptère mais sa mort n'a été forme
chilien exactement ne joue rien
lyn thériault si tu feras gaffe on voit
les sites où tu vas y l'iran dans le
reflet de deux lits des lunettes aux
ivoiriens je sais c'est pas joli joli
c'est pas joli joli mais je regardais je
vais aller twitch ce qui se passait
du coup h4 je comprends pourquoi
mach est pas mon façe pavant fab
peut-être food et de 20,3 maintenant
mais bon il va te refais repoussé cinq
noms oui bien sûr là peut-être tu prends
tu prends lève 5 kg 4,04 à s'éloigner
tout ça mais je pense du problème c'est
que tu fais et la turque a très bien
joué probable qu'il va faire food et 4
mais peut-être fou ou trois noms ouais
faut et 3 prendra prendra g53 k3 gk3 la
relève en rade et 5 euros 3 et si ta ta
ta ta ta ta je pouvais trop chambrer ses
intérêts il faut croire ça gagne juste
na waie
qu'est ce qu'il fait et calcules tu
penses ouais bon jour soit ben arfa
l'algérie calcul très vite sur un truc
non ok peut-être fou 3 pouces et 3 bah
je te bouges barre des 5
ouais bof ou 6,7 dans le gris foncé
droit sur lui résistant mais c'est la
dernière partie fable de la cadence
n'existe chez soi c'est pas quelques
mots clés mais la pomme rouge
bush en v 5 % des messages émanant cette
bombe à trois points d'écart mais c'est
plus serré que ce que j'attendais femmes
mais c est ce que c'est aussi
spectaculaire qui vous attendent
franchement enfin je m'attends à la même
chose avec un saut qui domine plus de
base je pensais qu'il sera à +5 tu vois
où + 6 avant les bullet noms évoqués se
doit vite quand il fait ce qu'il peut
il a band sous quoi c'est évident mais
il n'est pas ridicule autres il joue
beaucoup mieux que pour le premier match
un boisé je reprends je me pose ma 10e
journée tout devient chaud patate falga
pas on va repartir
du coup dans quelques minutes pour les
bullet ça va être chaud les tontons les
bluettes de partout
sarr est beau
ah ouais c'est ça ouais c'est pas c'est
pas spectaculaire mais c'est efficace un
souk est en train de parler
oui je joue un nouveau match très
ennuyeux c'est intéressant mais non je
pense à l'ailé je pense les bullet ça va
être pas mal quand est ce qu on s'est
serré les bullet c'est sympa quand c'est
serré les bullet ça envoie du lourd et
c'est cool on aime bien quand même bien
c'est plus amusant
allez les tontons fait des bulles est de
partout on envoie ou alors je met à
jouer en vue lettres qu'on ne regarde
pas leur truc je mets des pls bon mais
je pense que sauvé bien plus fort que
huit ambulances mais je sais pas on va
les voir à l'avant ce que vit 6 juin pas
de l'un était que 2006 et calque en
bullet ski sensiblement mon niveau de
mémoire et du coup contre un mec comme
souvent c'est un massacre
mais on va voir on va voir
ce qui sert barre et je pense à
recommencer à 20h40 fait
les tontons comment les joueurs sont pas
encore revenus
ça a duré 30 minutes 2 2 38 de bull est
donc de partir une hutte plus in
secondes par coup et donc ça renvoyée
pendant 30 minutes quel est ce que tu
peux jouer en mode software et je fais
en fait un des fois c'est juste que
d'après jean voix mais parfois ça
m'arrive de jouer solide solide 1
bon non mais trois points d'écart rien
n'est fait ça dépend si visite à
progresser en bullet et que c'est un peu
entraîné il peut il peut être bon et
tout peut arriver en bullet parce qu'il
suffit d'une baisse de régime une baisse
de forme et ça va en revanche s'il a peu
près au même niveau qu'il était contre
andreas ya normalement ça être un
massacre gens se rassied non mais ça va
repartir d'ici une trentaine de secondes
dès 20h40 analyse ça va y aller ça va
repartir des tontons il ya pas qui va
revenir qui revient juste à leur faim tu
reviens juste à l'heure il n'a pas
encore les écouteurs il nous entend pas
mais il est revenu juste juste à temps
parce que ça va partir maintenant ça va
partir dans quelques secondes
le dernier so spa j'ai pas commencé la
saison mais j'en sais pour l'avoir en
fait sont passionnés tricks et chiens
soient visite 50 en bullet contre 29 ans
normalement l'écart est assez grand fab
1 litres aux heures les trois ou cinq
mois ça va aller vite ce qui se passe
d'habitude c'est une juste part joueurs
donc pas trop le temps de réfléchir
et là ça va envoyer deux partout fable à
s'en voit de partout c'est aux parties
ok merci fax étendue fabien recomposée
voilà l'histoire g4 adéquat fera bien
pour le moment mais j'ai quatre arrivées
fab
tu ne vas pas rester sur sa faim vivent
allez vous
bonjour ne enfin de votre parti non
passage aux échecs h4 allez vous vous
êtes 2h40 qu'on est là mais enfin enfin
envoient du jeu saw qui rigole nous
couper nous toutes ses cadences quoi
laisser vrai échec ondulent est allé bim
pas encore une grande de mire 28,50 les
tontons ce qui est allé prendre l'option
b cet incroyable fab tu dis prend tous
les pions qui passe tout racheter il ya
peut-être là remplissent à l'oratoire
leuffel morbidité de bons cédé 5 bat les
héritiers chaud mais dans le chat soit
admise clic deux fois et la logique
attrait h 4 c'est pénalisant à l'ebit
une tour ses cinq matches cinq
s'échauffent avant fait on sait pas qui
est bien là non ça ne s'est pas de
chaîne info damages deux fois f67 et
père de charme mais là on va le voir tes
pairs le chat une expression de jade de
fable par bon départ de lyon a de
nouveau qui reviennent du coup on le
prend tout de suite ces chauffages ses
shows bij semblait deux bouquets prend
b2 fabriqué pour les deux halles et peut
aller et vous on va prendre ton français
de c'est fini et prendre les femmes
étaient nuls
tu es un maïs ça gagner dans qu'elle
prend b2 là je pense c'est un maïs fab
papier prend b2 gagner c'est quoi c'est
que c'est à la fac j'en peux plus même
moi je les fuis il n'y avait rien à voir
cliquez des cinq ramène tout comme ça
d'être dans l'autre sens quand il
souligné fall que vidic fait un beau
match mais de quel beau match tu parles
comme moi je suis tu as raté qui prend
b2
elle fait comme il était là comme il est
en sueur quand j'ai dit que que d'époque
c'est un beau match passer une b2
dire mais de quel beau match on parle
[Rires]
c'est génial je t'ai fait dès le contre
il prend à contretemps cac 3,27 formaté
mais à côté cheikh naïm et non plus là
il n'ya pas ne sait peut-être mieux
percer sa muraille mesdames d'une vidéo
c'est vrai ça marche quand même binebine
vidy bout ténue tard à quetta et prend
b2 t nul met à gagner
bouffard de g km pour fêter ça comme
s'il y en a qui est très heureux d'avoir
une canette elle est contente parce que
voilà tu me thème tout on peut pas
prendre la dame très décrié une source
raconte béton c'est nul mais tu as gagné
bout c'est chaud fab 2 points d'écart
fab rien n'est fait dans ce match qui
peut s'asseoir à la table de visite et
lui dire j'attaque mieux que toi le roi
personnes meilleurs talents du monde
plus de talent que carl scène visite
mais c'est la vérité mais bien sûr fab
plus de talent intentions ou sow il en
sueur issa il fait des petits signes de
tête non je ne peux pas jouer contre un
joueur aussi talentueux vie guide vie
dit allez les tontons et c'est la vérité
fabien delahaye tôt gecas et une télé
s'y perd le match
c'est génial il faire le match et ici ma
maxime perd le match
jeudi je demande à cheste encore un
budget quoi je prends la durée des jeux
la fracasse quoi aller fab déjà labat
j'avais une battre mais je sais pas où
aller enfin si je sais où aller mal et
pas chez moi chez mes parents ça que
j'avais quand j'étais gamin lequel
ericsson
fabre on en sueur n'échange pas les
dames jamais non non non tu n'as pas le
droit d'en attendre il m'a envoyé les
pions fab 1 va pas quoi vous la dame
pour les mater quoi ouais foot vouloir
opposer
c'est insupportable c'est insupportable
et fait reculer ces trois mais c'était
tellement écrit c'est gravé dans le
marbre fab je gagne rarement vu un mec
voulait autant faire nul même l'écho ne
fait pas ça c'est dire
allégée proposée
j'aime bien cette option l'onu il ya
plus de trucs oblige derniers actifs et
c'est la vérité fabien ça a été enlevé
cette option
quel accueil des givrés change toujours
des échanges aussi bien des pièces que
vu que wesley so personnes et super
concentré sur un puits si oui je
voudrais vraiment chaud pour bien
échangé destin que voilà on a changé
encore des pions oui j'ai essayé
d'échanger le fou contre ce cavalier
lorca retirant un truc c'est que peu de
contrats à tout moment après serre que
toi tu t'es c'est de gagner gagner
gagner le mec a essayé mille fois des
changes et puis à un moment donné il va
faire en plus étude d'un coup c'est toi
qui en sueur la preuve le cap est ok va
revenir à des trous partout quoi bref
fait kf5 gruyère ta position où il fait
qu'un nul tout de suite enfin fut
fantastique sont quand même un match
scii vont peut-être non tu peux essayer
de noms je prends tout de suite je fais
nul vital et revient et on visite une
quinte à la dune catalan allait oui il a
fait une fois aux quatre une partie
d'une partie marrante ça y est quand on
est retourné dans le truc non mais c'est
vrai que dubaï va avoir du mal en fait
t'as raison
ça va être hyper dur pour tout d'abord
qu'aucune pièce tu voulais t'amuser tu
vas te faire chier pour en trois arrêts
mr attention ça ne m'intéresse pas je
suis fait pour t'emmerder ça me fait
très attention à ça que tu demandais ce
que c'est les échecs sont un jeu ou pas
à quoi face à un jeu ou est ce une
torture on ne sait pas aller fab
on se chauffe de partout boom boom pow
est sur le coup les mecs jusqu'à ses
oreilles mais bon
aaa est fait attention des bébés 4 à
boom tour ces 8es bekkat attaque
allez les petits fauves y dit tu es
faire quoi
comme le gant est ce que si vide il
gagna tuque mondino du gange à boire
quand même pas cigale le speech est
d'accord c'est ghana compétition
peut-être pas mais mre aux quelques
commandes l'eau du gange
la véritable du gange après je pourrai
pas que la boire et ain defla covan et
je l'avais fait quoi des attaques un
truc je la mettrais ici et il y aura la
véritable eaux du gange à les français 1
d'allégeance des saoud homme c'est sa
pelote f6 pas besoin reste pas content
et satisfait j'ai un procès quand même
ça c'est bien je dormais en fait il est
super fort saut enfin le truc c'est que
s'ils avaient ainsi plus offensif
s'était ainsi elle pas peur de tout
quand enfin je passe il a peur aussi
facile moins de deux tendances
échangistes était beaucoup plus fort en
fait le père quand il était jeune il
envoyait 1,5
non ne porte la poisse de peut-être tout
à fait je voulais passer comme ça c'est
bien toi de tes mieux ni mr freeze
hiquily me aude grange me javel
historiquement du globe
michou d'auber les femmes faut défendre
sa fab
ça va être chaud défendre vos tiens je
te refais t il dans l'esprit comme j'ai
dit c'est bon allez il parle
mais bon bref c'est un canif
il se bat on sera perdu mais à titre y
mais il reste plus de temps en fin de
vie dite qui est là il est vite les
maths du couloir il évite tout sow qui
s'endort n'était tour 17 m et 1,17 à
fait ok mais
pour ces sept coups des 5 les trois
poupées 3t chose de changé envers un
buzz bien la foulée 3 cuil cinquante
premiers noms mais ok peut-être à mai a
fait 7 qui arrivent mais ok contre ce
crime faut aussi se dire tranche soit
peut-être même pas clair que d'hommes
chercher coin ouais mais ça c'est bien
joué ce qu'il veut faire tour un machin
2 ci dessous mais at war et cet échec je
suis père avec les honneurs menu plein
fouet ce retour et il était pas loin
l'autre partie sera quand même pour ces
cinq très bien jouer à je suis déçue la
fab
il aurait gagné visiteurs revenir un
point faible il revenait à portée de
fusil quoi n'importe quoi soit pareil
c'est pas la même chose
c'est ce que tu nous a appris par une
c'est une des choses qui restent qui
restera fab le stage de budapest
partout c'est pas pareil que 15 40
non mais c'est pas pareil
l'un des points qui valent cher à
effrayer des 15 35 points qui est plus
cher que 4,015 savoir
[Musique]
fax n'existait pas il faudrait
l'inventer quoi mais c'est tellement
beau comment tu as dis ça à budapest
quand a sorti ça c'est magique ce que je
n'ai rien fait si vous êtes en train de
vous apprendre un truc raciste est
génial la pédagogie plus attention les
meilleurs moments du stage barre était
tellement pls avec cette finale est en
jeu final de merde net s'est battu
pendant six ans quel bon match tu parles
ils étaient bien là c'est au corps
humain sont carénées c'est un peu un
lasso quoi il fait un voltigeur jour c4i
ouais les bureaux de qualité sinon vie
des gens s'amusent ya deux ans et cinq
pieds mal à échanger de partout ça je
vous écoute d'avancé 5 aux rousses
à quel solidité se sont trouvés vite
quoi c'est très bien mais il sait qu'il
objets et séguéla ça le fait marrer les
enfants rigoler j'ai dit j'ai
complètement relecture est ici c'est
super son chez lui on peut plus quoi ya
pas ton problème cet arrêt j'étais le
seul à penser à ce truc là c'est
peut-être jouable a apprécié cette
dérive cassée
sympa non le reste c'est du vent nul
quoi mais bon
messi 5 tours 7 4 puis rafion état
d'esprit votre souris doit pas faire
j'ai dit à david mc saïda temps il
serait peut-être temps c'est pas
dangereux la tour 17 d'un f4 et oui
c'est pas mal quand une merde vous
attaquez la tension dans les tours prend
et jesse ça allait aller vidy
mais oui petit balai comme un petit
miracle même temps il reste 15 minutes
pabx
il ya le temps de faire des choses mais
sérieux vise ici les hyper résistant
soir beaucoup plus fort que contre
adrien sernin e data crise crise husni
jeu peach pit rien donc qui comprend
rien même pas de quoi toi plus
d'ailleurs alors ben je sais pas mais
croque sifa être fait attention paquin
qui ne compte pas est parti alors que
dany à rennes je suis commente
automatiquement de christus regarda le
lay de démarrage vous abonner sur
youtube à la chaîne vitrine vous pouvez
trouver sur twitter si il ya des live
est plutôt sur twitter ne pas passer les
gens sur twitter on et achetons et choco
monsieur voulait taper ghimpu vais
mettre un petit polo et puis on fait des
live avec fabre ou si on prépare par
let's play narratif fab synthé quoi
enfin on va on va être à fond quoi enfin
l'heure du web bah moi je vais appeler
paul breitner tous les jours quand on
aura des infos sarko ancien joueur tu
seras entraîneur tu seras là on va
gueuler de partout quoi donc
tu avais un de gens qui regardent samson
l'écran quoi sans les partis regardant
mode radio mais en fait non mais sans
rigoler en fait quand on a parlé avec
vlad de comment faire les échecs matin
même pour la télé tout ça c est laide
maintient près des des semaines de
discussions c'est la conclusion à
laquelle on est arrivés les échecs se
commande comme une émission radio
personne n'a rien à [ __ ] de ce qui se
passe c'est génial voit les visites vie
dit vie dit non mais c'était bien que le
truc de vlad que quand quand il disait
pour les commentaires ah oui tu veux
dire que oui pourquoi oui l'armée genre
oui ce qui regarde les gens cdd série
maintenant et mais bon coup sûr une
spiritueux quoique de l'action qui du
suspense qui est truc marrant voilà
comme ça c'est pas un truc se passe rien
super chiant ok pourquoi les échecs tout
d'un coup chaud que ce soit super chiant
qui se passe rien mais que tu dis les
commentaires to call mais que cherche
cheap mais les commentaires de merde on
peut lui dire en face à un adversaire
vraiment et dans le sens de vlad donc le
dos qui le poursuit la raison cette rue
est fait quand tout ce que tu aurais
arrêté l'essai tout ce format là où tu
te marres vous c'est la folie et tout ça
quand autant alors la vie dit il et
chauffage ff3c qui m'as tu étais pas je
sais pas pourquoi
6 on se bat pour moi ce qu'on nomme g53
sa femme allait vite italie [ __ ] c'est
le fut champion de mr bergé ci sont
proches de bons échanges un email aux
deux allers-retours h7 nos pilotes fab
mais se marre il est très heureux
aïe pourquoi tu te marcquois olala ça
afin qu tellement déçu la visi mérite
tellement qu'ils méritent tellement de
revenir un point et nous offrir un gros
match à la fin un fab fab n'est à 3 j'en
peux plus fab fac je sus fab tension
accueille cinq ans la pj 4 m non en fait
visite il est très bien ça va gfk trop
prochain et l'on retrouve ce sourire de
saut quand il a arnaqué ça fait ça
franchement ça fait mal
quoi ouais mais faut reconnaître qu'on
est obligé de reconnaître ça serait bien
lui mettre magnus dans la gueule
il essaye de faire type nul bout alors
l'an dernier je crois qu'il avait joué
c'était faire défoncer romanus ça marche
plus fabrice 10 minutes faut absolument
la gagner et on est complètement raide
là il est en train de tout lui faire qui
dit il sait plus où il habite qu il sait
plus où est le gange de gauche c'est ou
au [ __ ] je ne sais plus well as et oui
c'est pris fin à 9 entre comme ça non
mais faut reconnaitre elle a super bien
joué et tout ça afin genre j'ai rien
contre les juges aiment pas son style
j'aime pas son style mais visite
originale avec 4.5 telle annonce suit la
cfu en mai visite la cam était
ambassadeur du boulot mais avec une soie
qui fait des déviations tu t'en fous de
mesures
alors tu peux encore défend [ __ ] tabac
chantal adam bien placé cancale auront
mal et des cinq ans mais il y aura des
pertes est détruit à jessains oui oui
c'est ça alors là c'est apprendre la
plus d'échec quand même peut-être se
faire mater nathan de 75 yuans à marfa
kenyans parlent tombe à 8 minutes 30 loi
est juste mais ceux qui jouent la montre
il attend pour mac dibango les bennes
comme iron man femmes
non mais c'est chaud non mais après faut
reconnaître une ferrari fait son match
et un seau et ça c'est une nouvelle
manière de jouer bling comme je l'espère
aux cinq qui évite pas nous a appris
quand j'étais petit mais bon c'est le
même conte moderne kaiser 10 grammes
annonce qui se marrent banon david
jovial ajs portail s'il fait il serait
heureux avant tout d'un coup ça y est
enfin
1100 habitants arrivés ils poussent
option avait du coup je pense en fait
s'il aimerait jouer comme ça
agressivement et mais peut-être il a
peur ou quoi un peu comme nous quand on
vous parfois saint-urbain jeunes en pls
pour rien la partie longue des fois
c'est flatteur c'est énervant fait
défaut d'être dominant perez constante
en fait tu as peut-être ils s'amusent
pas en fait quand il joue et éclairé de
jouer peut-être je pense qu'il est mal
la vie du temps ou qui ont un âge si ce
dommageable quand je joue je crois que
j'ai tout fait tous les coups du tennis
faire le malade c'est ça coup droit
revers amortie qua non mais sow après
quand il a attaqué à ces opportunités et
tous pousser une machine à janis est
d'un côté je suis pas sûr donc en fait
vidéosurveillance
pas de chance c'est peuvent jeu super
souvent dans les bons temps
à peut-être faire des parties de pale
blue line co kg 5
[Musique]
je ne peux que ça il est heureuse et
très heureux la cci ce mardi partout il
fait de s'ouvrir et super content va se
fait plaisir à voir fabien fait revenir
le chat sur le stream superbe il a gagné
le match
bon ok tu as joué solide on échange tout
et tout mais off n'est quand même pas si
si si ça tout de suite
la iii qui mène 1,50 la côte pour naka
c'est bien demain normalement oui hein
c'est une bonne cote après ça joue sur
le fait que la cave est pas en forme
mais une sinon comme il a toujours battu
maxime speech est assez avec des
certains écarts il est favori forcément
met donc un sacre en je pensais une
bonne cote je pensais qu'il serait plus
autour des 1 35 à 40 personnes
mais si je dis c'est pas demain c'est le
dieu et laitiers d'ingrid ou d'un match
à 9 soit un code non c'était sur une
petrov c'est à nantes qui veulent benko
contre dans la ronde de retour et du
coup on peut dire que à nantes a battu
tous aller où ils avaient préparé un nom
et jouit toujours pas très bien contre
ce genre d'ouverture sfr un londres
point qui est prof proche tout facile
d'amener vite vite car la tête dans le
seau pour ça que pour une fois je
préfère c'est d'être efficace
la honte et chloé décrite il reste 5
minutes fab sauty en train de s'envoler
vers la victoire
il semble inarrêtable fabien voilà ce
qu'on veut le bien là on a un peu
l'impression que c'est un droit je suis
de tours j'ai lu ton plus rs 4 minutes
40 c'est quasiment gagné
mathématiquement famille pourrait
presque se lever de sa chaise et le
match serait gagné ce qui serait quand
même un tour de force n'ont rien lâché
en fait c'est tellement heureux qu'enfin
j'ai fait un choix ça m'étonne que
d'être aussi sur un tueur
j'étais tellement ps pendant tout le
match soit tu t y vont s'afficher de
jouer tout
juste chier de jouer genre il a juste
peur en fait touché pas et c'est une
telle libération de gagner en fait pour
lui là c'est génial ten dam et fut de la
machine madame et fida machiste
maintenant avec la tour en c1 attaquent
l'iran plus ma médaille fut ta magie ça
c'est fort femme ne l'a pas vu mais bon
vous peut-être il l'a vu et que c'est de
la merde sinon tout est possible fab bon
madame g7 a jamais de match où tout faux
ça y est femme je pense que la cie gagne
je pense qu'il peut se déconnecter des
dénigrements et gagner quand même vous
partir en courant comme aux nordistes
qui il peut partir du coût énergétique
et des boisés très près tous quoi ils
surent j'hésite une star mais oui ma
chance à ingénieur le mec le net n'ont
pas foulé 2.39 ou c4 et le truc en
justice a fait tourner la pendule qui
joue pendant des plombes
mais ça ça gagne on est trop d'options
soit boni yayi boni ce qui fait durer le
plaisir
une ou deux mc sont way de max de max
c'est dommage que le score saloon
s'alourdissent pardon fable sur la fin
parce que s'il finit à plus 6 puis 7 ça
reflètera pas forcément le match parce
que ça a toujours été dans les puces 3 +
44 matches de sa tournée entre plus et
plus froid en fait en gros s'est
stabilisée par la bombe très très
longtemps donc ça aurait mérité de finir
à +3 mon avis mais pas plus ce que je
pense c'est la dernière fabrice eu 56 là
avec la seconde par coup là tu vois la
latence et tout ça ça devrait être la
dernière et ce serait bien une visite la
gagne fab nain juste pour un autre trop
lourd ouais bah je pense qu'ils méritent
non un bon le temps s'ils sont jugés 4
et donc n'oubliez pas après demain jeudi
19h mv elle n'a qu'à 2 je pense mieux
chou oise de cette époque et j'ai déjà
fait ça sera un gros match a t elle n'a
qu'à avec la documenta normalement oui
on ne sait pas après vous retrouve déjà
vous qu'on le retrouve et donc et donc
oui n'hésitez pas à suivre mettez le
petit coeur comme ça vous aurez à la
petite notification qui vous dira quand
le quand le live et en live
j'ai envie de te dire d'arc nabeul a
tout fait des overdoses aux cats à fait
quelconque on n'en voit plus pourtant
pas fou c'est pas grave ça ressemble à
faire voilà il reste 50 secondes de
match fab
d'où vient la côte de nuits pendant
lequel je sais pas vous allez jo marche
pas que ces marathons de bêtes un site
anglais tu peux pas parler de france 1
je crois c'est pas un site ce pas un
site français mais pour ceux qui sont à
l'étranger
je crois que c'est eux qui font les
côtes pour pour les matches de ce pitch
s
mais on sympa ça fait un petit pari de
regarder le match en fait illico alors
dit il
l'allégorie 3 2 ça va être pour un fab
pour visite ni sur unibet
tu peux évoquer des trucs sur un email
je pensais pas trop dur pour les
souhaits des chaînes plus de 28 minutes
tout le temps je pense les côtes sont
prévus pour faire 2-1 et aura des outils
charité chaque intermédiaire fab pas de
fourchette
so intraitable fab ce soir une fois que
vous le prendre des tombes et cinq ans
et trois rouges ouais c'est ça ça finit
ça fait cher au final favin plus si ça
ça reflète pas vraiment le scénario
parti quoi en faire attendez joue plus
quoi faire un fou ils sont un sur un
réseau qui est très heureux et rigolent
de partout la salle les rigoles de
partout et très content visite quand je
suis à risque ou quoi culture d'origine
a qualifié en demi finale et il
affrontera duda dou dou da la paix de la
haye qui était très vrai on a des gens
heureux qui vont se rencontrer plein de
bonheur quoi mais contre duda ça va être
intéressant opposition de style fabien
contre contre jean-christophe on appelle
aussi cricri dans le dans le jargon et
du coup ça on ne peut pas savoir suivre
attentivement quoi très loin que le
match bon c'était passionnant qui ne
mérite même
ouais on s'est marré mais pas grâce au
match non mais quelques petits moments à
certains vers la fin le bullet il ya eu
un petit il ya un petit frisson
quand même fab en bullet avec la
première on a vu la riche tu auras other
là on s'est dit ah machin passées sur
des jeux wii on va écouter les amis il
est temps de se quitter on se retrouvera
en direct donc je dit jeudi 19h mtn n'a
qu'à même endroit même même sean jones
aura tous